e
e e
being uh after 9: I'm going to uh call
uh the house Judiciary Committee uh to
order and I'm first going to recognize
representative Rambo to lead us in the
Pledge of
Allegiance Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liy and justice for
all thank you um representative Burch
reminds me that we we're waiting for a
clerk I got uh I got uh a text from
representative petel she's on her way so
uh we uh representative Burch would you
like to uh fill in for on a shortterm
basis no
idea representative kutab is not here
either so um well you know what actually
let me hang on one second let me get a
some not paper I I sort of I was a clerk
in finance my first term so I
but this is your bill too Mr chair so
you got go over
there can't Clerk or
chair sit in this seat sh no you can you
can so you know I I unfortunately since
since it is my bill and since I
therefore I can't be the clerk we're
going to recess just shortly until until
representative petel
arrives e
clerk is up to speed you ready okay
hope I can read your name
us
okay I'm going to open up the hearing on
House Bill 520 relative to author bring
hearings offices of the Department of
Education to issue subpoenas and I
recognize representative Lynn to
introduce the Bill thank you Mr chair
members of the committee um this bill
has been or a version of this bill has
been before this committee uh before uh
last year specifically and I think maybe
the year before that too um it basically
is a bill to authorize the Department of
Education to issue
subpoenas um in connection with
investigation
Andor
hearings um related to uh investigations
of uh the code of conduct for New
Hampshire Educators um the
um the bill uses I for lack of a better
term I would say the bill uses what I
would describe as sort of standard
subpoena language um and it's designed
to allow subpoenas to be issued uh both
during the investigatory stage of an
investigation
and then uh for subpoenas to be issued
um uh in connection with any
adjudicatory proceedings that may result
from uh the investig from the
investigation um I my recollection
is that there were
um
some assertions
made during previous uh iterations of
this bill um that this was uh that what
was being proposed here was really
highly unusual that it was not um that
this was not uh something that was uh
was sort of
standard uh in in this in the in either
the education context or an
administrative law generally which was
contrary to my understanding of of uh
how the law worked but I had occasion
and I know representative cutab will be
here before long she actually did some
she's she actually spent some time doing
some research on this and apparently
every other state in New England and she
I spoke to her this morning she quoted
Connecticut Connecticut has a statute
that is
virtually not I wouldn't say in wording
but virt in terms of purpose it
basically says the commissioner of
Education can issue subpoenas for
investigations I and in fact I don't
think I I don't think there it's even
limited to investigations of of uh um
teach teer credentialing I think it's
just basically some anything that's
within the jurisdiction of the uh the
Department of Education that they have
authority to investigate and again
according to according to representative
kutab uh that's that's the uh that's the
the situation throughout New England I I
would be very surprised if it wasn't the
situation you know in Most states I mean
again most if you're going to give an in
uh an agency the authority to
investigate and if you're going to give
an agency the authority to hold hearings
and take some kind of disciplinary
action it just makes sense that they
ought to have authority to to issue
subpoenas because otherwise I mean I
mean in a just stop and think of it the
equivalent this is it's not limited to
the education department but it's it's
this is this is the equivalent an admin
the administrative equivalent whether
it's the education department or the
department dep of Environmental Services
or whatever Department of Labor this is
the equivalent uh the administrative
equivalent of a of a trial there's uh
you know of of an investigation in let's
say that would be conducted by the
Attorney General's office or a county
attorney's office um uh and they have to
have the they have to have the ability
both to compel witnesses to appear and
compel the production of documents in
the investigative stage and then they
have to be able to compel both sides
both the the pro the proponent or the
prosecution so to speak whether it's
civil or criminal and the defense have
to have the ability to compel witnesses
to appear at the hearing that's really
all that this does it has Provisions in
it that allow for um uh a party that's
subpoena who thinks the subpoena is over
broad to move to quash The subpoena or
to limit The subpoena um I I you know to
the extent that there's that there's a
claim that this is somehow
unfair um uh or unprecedented I I submit
that it's just not it's just not correct
so I'm happy to answer any questions I
think it's a good I think it's a good
bill and U I hope you'll support
it representative
Smith thank you um good morning um can
you tell me who provides legal
representation for the Department of
educ in Connecticut who provides legal
representation you know I I I don't know
but I would I know they have an attorney
general's office uh in as I recall in
Connecticut the Attorney General's
office is limited unlike in New
Hampshire is limited to handling civil
matters but I suspect that it might be
that when
the when I don't know this but I'm
speculating I think this is probably you
know informed speculation that the
Department of
Education handles things internally
within the Department of Education but
if they have to go to court then the it
would be the Attorney General
customarily is the is the agency that
represents the state or its agencies in
court so I would suspect that would be
the case in
Connecticut uh thank you very much I'm
not going to do what I'd like to do
which is to ask you the same question
about uh Massachusetts Vermont Maine and
anybody else I might have Rhode Island I
didn't want to forget Rhode Island of
course um um is it uh not true Mr
chairman that in um the state of New
Hampshire which likes to do things its
own way it is the attorney general that
provides uh legal
representation uh for the Department of
Education when you say provides legal
representation I think I I I I guess I I
need to know exactly what you mean by
that I think it is certainly true that
if the Department of Education is going
to have to appear in court that it's the
Attorney General's office that does the
representation but in term you know I
think that's true really for any um
agency uh maybe there's maybe there's
some exceptions but I would be surprised
I I think generally the attorney general
pro provides the
Inc Court representation for agencies
but I think that's this is not dealing
with Inc Court representation it's
dealing with administrative proceedings
and I think in administrative
proceedings um it's it's not at all
unusual for the for the agency to handle
its own administrative proceedings um um
thank you very much I believe that what
has historically been true is it's the
department of of justice that has
handled those responsibilities for the
Department of Education but you're the
expert I'm not thank you representative
Paige thank you uh Mr chair and thank
you Mr chair for taking my question I
guess on both sides um to paraphrase Yi
Bara this is like deja vu all over again
again um I remember the origins of this
bill coming from the divisive Concepts
Bill and empowering the um Commissioner
of Education to um prosecute cases on
behalf of parents that
that alleged there was some violation of
that and then I lost track of that but
it's somewhere I think it's enjoined in
the first circuit or something I've lost
track but in any event in the multiple
rounds of testimony on that we had the
Department of Education investigator
come and
testify and he said he was doing a great
job at his job in terms of policing for
lack of a better term um teachers that
may have be up for losing their license
as I recall he sort of suggested
this would be another tool in his
toolbox to to get this but he didn't
indicate that there was a problem we
were trying to solve and so um I guess
I'm putting my little conservative hat
on again less government is more for me
but I'm wondering has there been any
indication from the Department that they
are unable to do their job since the
last time we heard about this to now
that they would need this power
have I heard something since the LA I
guess I have to say my my recollection
of the earlier test I mean I I think I
largely agree with what you said that
the the the investigator from the
Department I think he was if I recall a
former state police officer um I think
he did say as you as you indicate that
you know there there generally has been
no problem in getting information I
think he did say that there if I recall
that there were a couple of instances
where there was a timing issue of things
getting delayed more than he would have
been comfortable with but I but I
believe I believe we heard testimony
from some witness and I can't tell you
who it was that in indicating that there
were some school districts that were
simply saying we're not giving you the
information um uh now whether that I the
the exact context of that I don't
remember but I do I do remember that
there was some testimony to that effect
so you know I guess what what I would
say as a response to your question is I
think it makes sense for as I said
before if an agency has the authority to
conduct investigations and to hold
hearings they it just makes sense that
they ought to have a power to compel
people to comply they it's somebody
shouldn't be a you know if the if the
Department of Education is conducting an
investigation of of an educator um and
wants to get documents or records or
Witnesses the the respondent shouldn't
be ble to say go pound sand and and you
know without a subpoena power that sort
of effectively is give you give them
that Authority and I don't think they
should have
that representative
buron thank you Mr
chair I just wanted to ask simply I wish
I had somebody in front of me that has
experienced this process you know
because at this point I don't feel like
I have enough information because I
don't know typically what happens to the
parties like CU here it says any cost
incurred issuing a subpoena is the
responsibility of the party requesting
it unless determined there's an unless
there that bothers me determined by the
officer yeah by the treny officer I
don't know but that's what I'm feeling
comfortable on um I feel like we're all
kind of a little know a little bit about
it
but I feel like I don't know
enough and I've been on a school board
for 12 years so this is a time for
questions
yeah I'm done I just wanted to say that
I'm uncomfortable about it just simply
because I don't feel like I have enough
information all right representative
Birch thank you Mr chair Mr chair um I
I'm following up in your analogy of this
to a trial which is some respects it is
um unless I'm missing it it's true that
that under this bill one side gets to
subpoena and the other side doesn't now
that seem we're we're in the we're here
in the bill did I miss saying that all
parties have a similar right so right so
I think here here's here's the analysis
if you look at
sections uh Roman numeral
13 in section one of the bill and you go
from
13A through uh
13d I'm sorry
13A yeah 13A through 13d those are uh
the the the paragraphs and subparagraphs
that deal with what I would refer to as
investigative subpoenas which would be
issued only by the only in in favor of
the party conducting the investigation
draw the analogy to the grand jury the
gr the the state can subpoena witnesses
to the grand jury the defendant doesn't
get to do that doesn't have subpoena
power to to subpoena people to the grand
jury paragraph e says that any
information that is in that is gathered
during the investigative process shall
be a shall be made available to both
parties at the at the proceeding that
may result from the investigation and
then particularly paragraph X
says that in any adjudicatory
proceeding um a hearings officer May
issue subpoenas to both sides so that
that's the equivalent of the trial
subpoenas if you
will assuming that there's basically two
sides here you've got the Department of
Education and the um the person being uh
teacher whatever being investigated
if I understand your
answer that the one side whether it's at
the Grand Jury level or later adud
judicatory
level has the sole authority to collect
the information that information must be
shared but it's the information is
limited to what the Department of
Education wants to produce and does not
cover what the teacher may want produced
is that correct well if you're saying
during the investigative stage in either
stage well in I think there's a big
difference in the investigative stage it
is it it is certainly true that and
again I draw the analogy to the criminal
process but but I think in any in any in
any sort of administrative process it
would be the same would be true in in
the investigative stage it's the body
that's doing the investigation that has
the authority to compel people to comply
now if a respondant knows that they're
under investigation and I suspect it
would be a rare case where they didn't
can they ask people to voluntarily
provide them with information of course
but they I don't think and you correct
me if I'm if I missed something but I
don't think in any criminal process that
I'm aware of that during the
investigative stage the defendant or
prospective defendant gets to subpoena
people to come where to the there's no
there's no case so they don't get the
subpoena people to come to the grand
jury that's for I don't want to belabor
the question but when it moves to the
adjudicatory stage right there the
evidence that the Department of
Education wants and people want is
available right but there's no subpoena
power for the the accused so to speak to
have the equivalent ability to subpoena
documents and people no that's not true
that's what that's exactly what
subsection F says if once you get to the
once you get to the adjudicatory stage
and there's a hearing of course the def
the the the respondent the teacher can
of course ask to have subpoenas issued
for you know exculpatory evidence or
evidence that favors a defense of course
they can do that that's what f is
designed to cover okay thank you
representative
andreos thank you Mr vice sh thank you
Mr chair for taking my question as a
citizen I've had several dealings with
doe and I've always been told what a
matter I take to him that we do not have
statutory Authority just what statutory
Authority does the doe have to do
investigations
that's well I I that's I have to say
that as I sit here right now I know that
they have the authority to do
investigation of the credentialing of
teachers and whether or not they have
violated you know the their the
credentialing statutes I assume that
they have other uh you know uh authority
to do investigations I mean for for
example if I suppose if they um if they
thought that somebody they had a
contract with with was not
being um you know was not complying with
the contract or something I would assume
they could investigate that but I you
know without having looked at it I I
believe we have a witness here from the
Department of Education who probably is
much more familiar with that and could
answer it so that I think they're in
they're I guess I would say the the best
I can tell you is I would assume they
have investigations to do in other
authority to do investigations in other
areas but I don't know that for sure
okay thank you representative
organ thank you very much Mr chair thank
you and well thank you very much Mr uh
usual sheriff for taking my taking my
question so this as I see in um
obviously in line five and six it's
limited to one particular aspect of what
the doe oversees which is the code of
conduct for New Hampshire Educators and
I wait just glancing quickly at the law
looks like that's not just teachers but
par professionals and everybody works
directly with students but
um why do we exclude other people and
entities that Doe works with such as uh
you know we've had issues with you
mentioned vendors you provide services
we had some somewhat poent somewhat
controversial organizations for example
providing uh course materials to the
schools also um we've had issues we've
had issues with we often many charter
schools are often founded and failed so
you often wonder like uh I don't think
there's been any Criminal cases resolve
those we want do Wonder like
about you might have a situation where
you want to investigate that and then of
course you have the E EFA program which
the administrations was turned over you
know to a small nonprofit organization
based in based based out of state and
there's very poor oversight of it but
you could certainly imagine uh and there
already was some waste fraud and if he's
found is a very limited audit so like U
with this why doesn't this give the DOE
The Authority The subpoena um those
three types of entities vendors uh
Charter School boards at fail and um the
EFA U scholarship
organization I'm I'm really very glad
that you asked that question
representative Oregon because my
recollection is that way back when a
year ago or two years ago when there was
a first draft of this legislation it was
broader it said that anything that the
Department of Education
I'm I'm summarizing here but my
recollection is it would have given the
Department of Education broad subpoena
power to issue subpoenas in connection
with anything that they had the
authority to investigate and my
recollection is that um people on on on
the loyal opposition side of the of uh
to to this issue were very concerned
about that oh this is much too broad you
know it should be limited to uh to to
teacher credentialing and so that's what
that's what this does it limits it to
teacher credential um if you know um and
so I that's that's the short answer to
your question it's done that way in the
hopes that that would eliminate the
objections of some people that objected
to the subpoena power being too broad
fair enough I I think I did
legislation thank you chair and thank
you chair uh for the question um it's
actually a similar question so when it
says new Hampshire Educators is that
only Public Schools or he mentioned
Charter Schools but also like um you
know private colleges and things like
that is that included in New Hampshire
Educators yeah I believe it's it's Ed as
I understand it's Educators that have
credentials now my understanding is that
Educators that have credentials are not
limited to public school teachers so if
there you know if there's a qu if
there's a claim that a credentialed
educator who was not teaching in a
public school had you know came under
investig then this would
apply any other questions representative
TR
tur thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking the question um thinking back to
the last time we heard the similar bill
um I think one of the the takeaways that
I recall was that that this can already
be done through the Attorney General's
office so maybe it builds on the
question that that representative Smith
started off asking is there a problem in
which this can't be done through the
Attorney General's office currently in
other words is is it necessary to set up
this whole separate structure well you
know I guess what I would say is is this
I think if your question
is could the Attorney
General take over if you will the the
sort of uh you know the
investigation of teacher credentialing
by the Department of Education in some
particular case could they do that I
think the answer is probably they could
I I would defer to representative foron
if unless there's something in the
statute that I'm you know I'm just not
aware of right now but I would think the
answer to that is probably yes but I
think that's you know I think that would
be
true really of of almost any
administrative investigation I assume
the Attorney General would have that
Authority if they wanted to but to to me
I think that's that's not an appropriate
answer because
the the the agencies thems they conduct
these investigations internally and they
should at least in my view they should
be able to do that can I do a followup
yes follow up um so just to clarify what
I was really asking was just about the
subpoena I I understand that the
Department of Education would be the one
that would have to investigate the
actual underlying matter I guess the
question is if they were running into a
roadblock and they felt like you know
compulsory participation was needed
my understanding is they could go to the
the Attorney General's office to seek
the just the subpoena not to turn over
the whole
process see just this well you know I I
mean I think I I guess you know I'm as
I'm thinking this through I think that
without some without some
Authority
giving giving the authority to
compel the production of documents or
Witnesses in connection with an
administrative
investigation um I don't I don't think
that that would I don't think that the
Attorney General could do that I think
what the attorney if what the Attorney
General would have to do I think would
be to would be to go to court and seek a
subpoena um in from the court because I
don't I don't think that there's a
statute that generally gives the
Attorney General the authority to issue
subpoenas
in education matters I think I I think
you know the Attorney General I I
definitely agree the Attorney General
could go to court and petition for the
issuance of a subpoena but it it seems
to me that you know just as we talk
about that that would be a pretty
cumbersome procedure in other words
you'd have you know imagine if that were
true imagine if that were true just
throughout the administrative uh regime
so that you know the department of admin
of Environmental Services they're
conducting an investigation they want
want to get records um they have to go
to the Attorney General's office to go
to court to get the records or the
Department of Labor or whatever it just
seems like that is a kind of an
awkward uh procedure to place any agency
in where they're where they're
conducting and have the authority to
conduct their own
investigations representative
Burch thank you uh I notice and this I'm
wondering if you would accept or or
think it wise for an amendment I'm
noticing in section f as you point out
yeah a hearing officer May issue okay
may or may not no standards if you go
to uh section A right it's a shall issue
with a few caveats it's got to be uh
good faith and likely to be material
would you
have an objection to an
amendment to
F that changes the May issue to a shall
issue uh under the same criteria earlier
so that I mean I understand the hearing
officer is part of the Department of
Education and may just have a point of
view about um relative merits in the law
like a sh issue is more protective of
the um I don't want to use the word
accused but you know what I mean right
uh rather than being may may get a
subpoena issue may not without any
standards you know what I guess what I
would say to that is this I I would have
no problem with changing the May to
Shell if you could if you added language
that said for example shell issue The
subpoena for the ATT of witnesses or the
production of books papers documents and
other items uh on behalf of the
Department of the Ed or the certified
educator
um I if we put language in there saying
you
know uh shell issues penis for materials
uh relevant and material to the because
I think I mean I actually think
that if the the shell in subsection a
with the with the two then caveat of
what has to be shown is kind of the the
equivalent of the may I mean it's not I
agree it's not exactly the same but it
does the the the caveats in one and two
under subsection a are sort of turn the
shell into shell as long as you satisfy
these
things I think that to me that's that's
roughly the equivalent of the May in F
but I wouldn't have a problem with
changing it to Shell if you put it in
it's got to be material and relevant
because otherwise you can't have you
know either side shouldn't be able to
ask for a subpoena for just
anything thank you representative
beron thank you I was just curious
because usually a school district or a
school itself would be involved in this
and I don't see anywhere here how or if
they need to be communicated in in a
certain way so I'm just
I'm just confused if you know anything
about the fact that where does a school
district or a school whatnot fall in
this but as I understand it the the the
proceeding the credentialing
investigation proceedings are directed
against a credential educator um now
obviously that person or I shouldn't say
Obviously but in all likelihood that
person works for a school district um
the you know and presumably one of the
one of the likely places I would think
that a subpoena particularly for books
and records and you know other kind of
things might be issued would be to the
school district so that's you know I
think they the way that they would be
involved is if the
subpoena um was issued to the school
district to produce certain books or
records or um uh you know payroll
records or whatever uh curricular
records or something like that I I would
assume that then the school district
would be involved in that
way thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Brian Hawkins
thank you Mr chairman um members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Brian Hawkins I'm here representing Nea
New Hampshire um we represent um
thousands of Educators across the state
um in collective bargaining and and um
and some in these sorts of proceedings
um although I'm not I don't conduct
these uh representations myself I'll do
my best to answer any questions that you
have after testimony and if I can't
answer them I'd be happy to get you the
answers to those um but this is I think
the third time uh We've uh had a similar
bill in the last few years we are still
here in opposition to the bill um we
feel first uh the first question the
committee should answer before before
even examining the language of this bill
ought to be um is it necessary for the
commissioner of Education or the
Department of
Education uh to be able to obtain
subpoena Authority uh to properly carry
out their charge under the New Hampshire
educator code of conduct um and as was
noted earlier uh in subcommittees in
hearings um the department has
consistently told the legislature each
time uh the issue has come before you
that the authority was a prospective
need if there were documents that a
school district simply would not allow
them access to um the question of
whether there documents not being made
available to them was asked uh in as I
said a retain Bill subcommittee meeting
follow-up
conversations and um the bill heard last
year in committee the as far as I could
tell and I I'm happy to be corrected the
answer was still no um and there was not
anything that the department could not
view in determining whether to recommend
whether a violation had occurred uh and
and a punishment was warranted um so and
to to the bill itself uh we still feel
that this is um fundamentally unfair um
with respect to um uh credential holders
uh due process rights um and um first I
I'll bring up a couple points on this
first the department essentially is
asking for the ability to issue
subpoenas to solicit information during
investigations uh yet as was again noted
earlier there was no Provisions that
this uh subject educator may also issue
subpoenas which would assist in their
defense during the investigation period
I think that's important partly because
um as I've been told the experience here
is the investigatory
phase uh that this rarely gets to an
adjud adjudicatory phase and so um most
often that is the phase that we are
talking about and so when you're talking
about being able to uh have the
information necessary to make decisions
about uh whether you're going to accept
a
recommended um sanction from the
Department um having all of that
information is critical to the
credential holder um in the rules I
don't have the specific timeline in
front of me but there is a there is a
prescribed timeline that an edge care
has to make that decision um that
involves their career uh as to uh and
and having uh
an adequate amount of time to uh and
information to make that decision is
really critical um and so that's one of
the areas where I think that it's not
necessarily an Apples to Apples just
because one state has subpoena Authority
for their their education department um
we should too the the processes are are
are different the experience is
different and so
um so um the the
and and and the department of course
will have all that information well
beforehand so as before uh the language
uh is not restrictive to certain code of
conduct
violations um and subpoenas in the
investigatory phase based on these
standards um brings us back to concerns
about how broad they are uh you know for
example um in the
criteria um that for the hearings office
it states that um the material would be
reason reasonably likely to be material
and we think that's broad um and so
we're concerned that that could mean
anything and
everything um I'll close with just some
context for this legislative session um
last year we were also part of the
reason we were concerned about adding
this authority to the Departments was
because there was a simultaneous process
going on to change the rules the
investigatory proceedings and procedures
under the code of conduct through the
rulemaking process um and so we were we
were doing two
simultaneous processes one we were
changing the rules and then we were also
adding this additional Authority um and
you know at that point we didn't know
what Authority we were adding for
subpoenas we were adding to
uh what process we were adding that
authority to so um but this year uh I
think there it's important for the
committee to understand there there's
also several uh attempts to expand the
educator code of conduct going on in
other committees and so um I think
that's important when you're talking
about broadening the scope of the code
of conduct um across the hall um where I
spent a lot more time than in the
Judiciary Committee
um the house bill 235 would allow the
State Board to write uh an entirely new
category of unnamed responsibilities to
the code of
conduct
um Senate Bill 96 uh being heard in the
Senate uh around mandatory disclosure
also contains subjective and vague
standards for divulging information in
response to written inquiries um and
that bill also contains language saying
it must be add to the educator code of
conduct and be considered a violation of
the code of conduct so
um for those reasons we have a concern
that this um that this bill is as I said
unnecessary um and I I would urge the
committee to also look at those other
factors when considering whether we need
to uh Grant this Authority uh when we're
not sure what kind of educator code of
conduct we're even talking about by the
end of the session so um I'll close with
that and happy to take any questions
that I can okay so I guess I have a
question yep um as far as subpoena power
for both the Department of Education and
the respondant it sounded like from your
testimony you
agree that subpoena power is important
critical to get accurate and thorough
information however you want it for both
parties but it sounds like you agree
that that's critical though to that
power yeah thank thank you for the
question I um and if uh it let me
clarify um I don't think that this is a
necessary power for the Department to
have um I my comments about both sides
really had to do with uh within the
context of this specific Bill not uh
generally whether that power is
necessary representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my questions I have
two quick questions I'm going to give a
two second thing I was a registered
nurse who had a license and I was
subpoena twice to speak in um an
incident that occurred with another
nurse um and I don't I wonder why you
think that's any different and my second
question is have you heard of
sealed um sealed what do you call them
on something sealed sealed
documents uh where um in uh uh something
has come up in you know in a school with
a an educator or an employee and they
have been given and and in businesses
where they have been given the option of
well you have a choice we'll either fire
you or you can quit and we will seal the
documents the complaint those are my two
questions thank you
sure
um well uh taking the second one first I
mean I I am familiar that sometimes in
employment situations you have those
sorts
of uh Arrangements I know there have
been bills that
specifically uh deal with that but um
I'm not sure that
it's necessarily relevant to this bill
although I would say you know um it at
least as I can it it doesn't seem as
though there is um I think there's a
question about what could be subpoenaed
here so you know whether that's included
whether you're talking about any uh are
there um items that are exempt under 91a
from disclosure that are also being able
to be subpoenaed um I think that's
unclear from the bill um and then to the
to the uh question around
other uh professional license with the
nurse um I think that it's a different
um situation here uh there was Authority
granted to um I guess in that case it
would be oplc or Board of Nursing I
guess um uh not to the Department of
Education I think if anything the track
record in the last several years um and
Beyond I think should give pause about
whether we're um allowing a a an
innately in at times political
Department to to to be able to issue
subpoenas and I know that I Pro I know a
lot of you probably won't agree with
that um but uh I think that's a reason
to to give pause about whether you um
ought to Grant this
Authority followup what do you mean by
track record well I I mean I I'll be
happy to share the the um you know there
was a story not not long ago about um
the track record of the commissioner and
the use of authority to um drive a
certain agenda and so I I don't think
that is
um I I think that that should give the
committee pause when it comes to
subpoena Authority one but two when it
comes to subpoena Authority and any code
of conduct violation like I said when
there are numerous bill ills the session
that are proposing to expand the code of
conduct might I for the record say that
I feel that that was a very
inappropriate um remark bringing up the
the uh track record of the Department of
Education yeah we don't really speak
about motives but uh representative uh
Morton thank you thank you for the
question and um when we talk about track
records I'm not going to look at the
test scores that we have in the state um
that being said um as far as uh my
career I'm regulated by the insurance
department here in the state and
regulated by the SEC and the
FDC why shouldn't Educators be shouldn't
there be better oversight well the
educators are regulated under um well
not saying that they're not regulated
but why shouldn't there be better
oversight CU that's what this is
about I mean you spoke for about 5
minutes and said like two words
not I'm not sure there's a question
there Mr chairman and so I'll okay
representative mayos thank you sorry
thank you Mr Vice chair and thank you
for taking my question um you spoke
about pending changes to the rules of
the Department of Education and as I was
wondering whether um those rules have
been finalized and whether any of them
impact the issuance of subpoenas or any
of the the issues that we're dealing
with
here um there there there was a fi
finalized rules uh changes in the
investigatory process that were
finalized last year I'd be happy to send
those uh to the committee uh they dealed
with a variety of issues from timelines
to uh you know notice around um uh to
the credential holder when they're under
investigation um and you know
what the
uh what that notice needed to include
when if they are placed under an
official investigation um so it it deal
with a variety I think they are uh in
some cases connected and some cases you
know indirectly um to uh to The subpoena
Authority any other questions
representative
Bergeron thank you Mr co-chair Mr chair
I'm just going to ask you a question
because I know that you've been
in a lot of Education um settings but at
this point I had asked earlier the fact
that I was a little bothered where it
doesn't have anything here about a
school or a school district I just I
guess I'm ba based on your opinion and
what you're reading here do you feel
that's a critical step to actually have
in here as far as the responsibility of
a district like for example sure um so
um
there there may be other uh you know
Witnesses coming up who can speak
directly from the school district uh
point of view um when I send you the
investigatory rules I I do believe that
they're it speaks to uh you know there
are Provisions about notice when when
someone is under investigation notice to
the to the school that that that
credential holder is under
investigation um but off the top of my
head I wouldn't be able to give you a
comprehensive uh view of the of all the
rules that speak specifically to the
school district's I'm just asking rle if
follow if you think that's a good
idea um I I to actually have it that's
what I'm saying yeah I I I think the
more clear you make any law the the
better any other questions we just don't
know what it is seeing none thank you
thank
you uh Diana Fenton is that right
good
morning thank you for having me for the
record my name is Diana Fenton I'm an
attorney with the Department of
Education it is my hope today to answer
some of the questions that were raised
um so in the first instance uh thank you
than you for your consideration of this
bill I know it's been brought forward
many times it is very important to the
Department of Education uh for this
committee to consider our requests to
have subpoena power we are doing so to
be proactive in our
investigations um the department does
have limited Authority and limited
oversight of schools but in RSA 21 N9
and I'm happy to repeat that legal
reference I am an attorney and I can't
stand when people just throw me legal
references so RSA 21
N9 it sets forth the rulle making
Authority now the Department of
Education is different from a lot of
other state agencies in that the
department itself does not have rul
making Authority it is the Board of
Education that has the ru making
Authority so when you look at RSA 21 N9
it says rul making for the Board of
Education shall adopt rules in these
various areas and if you look at the
very end of the statute it is Roman
numeral
2 Double little
c
one so 21 N9 Roman numeral
2 Double little c one see I wish I had a
whiteboard so I can write it up here but
I am not an educator I'm an attorney so
please forgive
me but that is where House
Education established the department um
The Establishment and enforcement of a
code of ethics and code of conduct for
licensed or certified
Educators there was a question whether a
licensed or certified educator could be
in a a private school or we call
non-public school the answer to that is
yes they could be there is a question as
to whether or not this U applies to
higher education no it does
not there is a question as to whether or
not licensed or certified Educators
could be in charter schools yes they
could be charter schools are not
required to have everyone be a licensed
or certified educator but they do have
to have a certain number so we could get
a call from a charter school and the
person could be an unlicensed
educator we could get a call from a
charter school and the person could be a
licensed
educator and it within this rul making
Authority again not Authority by the
Department of Education but the Board of
Education they set forth these
professional codes shall include a
statement of purpose and standards
defining each of the four primary
principles and they set forth four
principles when the department with
under the Board of Education Authority
undertook rul making it became this
document right here the code of conduct
it is available on our website but
because this governs an individual's
license a teacher's license we felt the
need to put it into a booklet to make it
accessible to let the field know that
this is your guiding document I have
these available if anyone would like
them we have them at the
department and in large part and of just
very briefly the the principles are the
first one is responsibility to the
education profession and educational
professionals the second one is
responsibility to students the third is
responsibility to the school community
and the fourth is responsible and
ethical use of Technology as it relates
to students schools and other
educational professionals so this is the
guiding document for licens educators as
I mentioned I'm not an
educator I'm an attorney and similar to
representative Lynn we have our own code
of ethics and standards for for
attorneys so all that being said there
was a question about the role of the
Attorney General's office the role of
the Attorney General's office they are
the Department's civil
councel as representative Lynn said if
the department gets sued it is the
Attorney General's office that will
represent the state agency in a court of
law but the Attorney General's office
defers to the state agency whether it's
the Department of Education or the
Department of Labor or any other state
agency to do its own oversight
on on the field that they regulate and
so the Department of Education or rather
the Attorney General's office would not
come into the Department of Education
and conduct one of these Administrative
Hearings as it pertains to an
individual's teaching
credential there was another question
posed and this has um had a lot of
traction over the past years as this
bill has been uh discussed and worked on
as to whether or not the Attorney
General's office can obtain a subpoena
on behalf of another state agency in
this instance the Department of
Education my understanding and speaking
with the Attorney General's office is
that they cannot that is not a role that
they would serve I think to
representative Lynn's point that would
be very it be a very onerous uh feature
if they were to take that on for every
state agency and more to the point if
the agency doesn't have the authority in
statute to seek a subpoena it would
probably be the wrong Avenue for the
agency to then ask another agency to
obtain that document for them which is
why the department is here for House
Bill 520 um you know the question has
also come up can you give an instance in
which this was this was necessary in
which it was needed so let me give you a
quick overview in terms of how the
department operates on these
cases this document that I've referenced
the code of conduct if you were to look
in our rules you would find it under
ed510 ed510 sets forth those four
principles and there's another principle
the the duty to report it sets out those
principles as I mentioned that govern
someone's teaching
credential it is the ed5 11s that set
forth the due process that
governs when the department undertakes
takes an
investigation and if an individual is
placed under investigation and that is a
term of art under our uh under our Ed
511s that individual is noticed they
receive a letter from the Department
sent certified mail letting them know
the department has opened an
investigation here's the alleged
violation this is the principle We
Believe has been violated and here's the
factual
basis the superintendent of the employe
school district is also notified so to
your point the school is involved in
that the department really values its
connections and its working
relationships with the field that
includes credential holders non-
credential holders school districts and
superintendents so we did not want to
place someone under investigation and
not notify the
superintendent because it really is a
working relationship in large part it is
the school district that will undertake
the investigation this is the difference
between
employment and
lure and so the school district
typically will undertake the
investigation and we've seen that in
some high-profile cases namely uh there
was a case in 2018 maybe early 2019 here
in conquer with uh an individual a
licens educator who was having sexual
relationships with with students uh
underage girls it was the school
district that hired an outside
investigator has nothing to do with the
Department of Education hired an outside
investigator to come in and do a full
investigation right that was the school
district's decision to hire an attorney
to come in and do a full-blown
investigation into that issue because it
is the school district who makes that
decision to hire someone to do an
investigation that investigation that
report belongs to the school
district it doesn't belong to the
Department of Education it belongs to
the school district they paid for it it
is their
product and the case out of concrete is
a great
example that
educator uh committed sexual assault is
currently in prison in Massachusetts for
having committed sexual assault on Young
girls and there was another young victim
involved as
well and yet the department could not
simply just say the concrete School
District can I have a copy of the
report we we it was very challenging to
get a copy of that report and in fact I
had to go to the attorney's office to
view it and I was not allowed to take
it I was not allowed to have a copy of
it so in terms of the Department's
ability to move forward in taking that
that particular educator to a hearing to
obtain that Educator's license I would
need as part of due process and
fundamental fairness to provide that
report to the credential
holder but I didn't have
it and so these are some of the things
that these are some of the Practical
realities that the department strug
struggles with and deals with and
ultimately in that instance the
credential holder turned his license
over he surrendered it right it worked
out and that is what the department has
been successful at doing but given the
nature of what the department is working
on child safety and I would encourage
each of you to look at those four
principles that are laid out in the code
of conduct and what you will see is a
real emphasis on child
safety so I am not here to say in the
case of you know State versus Jones we
were not not able to get this document
and this is why we need it I am here to
say given the code of conduct given the
important work the department does in
making sure that credential holders are
appropriate around children we would
like this subpoena power as a tool in
the toolbox we don't need it as a first
line of defense again we really do value
our relationship with the field and
school districts and and we pride
ourselves on a good working relationship
with the school because much to your
points uh representative the schools are
a critical part of this we cannot do
these investigations without our
partners and the only instance in which
the department typically takes the lead
if you will um and does not defer to the
school district to to do the uh initial
investigation is in cases that are older
so we have had instances very small
number of cases but we have had
instances in people coming forward and
saying you know back in the 90s back
back in the early 2000s I had a
relationship with an
educator and and that individual is is
still in the school district and I'm
concerned um if that person's safer and
children and in that instance it will
typically be the Department of Education
that will initiate and lead the
investigation and not the district and
we have had those cases they typically
have made the news um but as
always I have talked way too much as
lawyers tend to do so I will open myself
up to questions I thank you for your
time and your patience I know this bill
has kind of been the cat that we fed
once and keeps coming back um so I
appreciate your time and your patience
I'm happy to take any questions it was
excellent information by the way so I
appreciate that any questions over there
representative
bir thank you Mr chair thank you uh
witness that's all right I've been
called worse attorney fon
um and I appreciate your self-reflection
at the end of your comments uh I have a
simple question that hopefully will'll
just have a very short answer and that
is can you
quantify the number of cases that the D
OE has not been able
to
um uh effectively access information for
each of the past five years
we have been able to access the
information that we need thank you
that's all I asked representative Perez
thank you thanks for taking my question
um if a a complaint is issued against a
in a a teacher that might affect their
credentials and that complaint goes to
the um principal and then to the um the
SAU superintendent
is there anything mandating that they
have to bring it to the Department of
Education because my concern is the
incidences that might affect someone's
credentialing that never make it to
you thank you for the
question within the code of conduct
there is a duty to report um the
superintendent has a obligation to
report to the Department of Education if
they believe the there is a violation of
the code of conduct much to your point
however I think there are a lot of
instances in which a school district
policy could be violated but does not
affect the code of conduct there are
many many policies whether it's people
showing up on time or classroom
management or classroom organization
that might have an effect at the local
school district is level it might very
well be an employment issue but it does
not rise to the level of the code of
conduct again I would encourage all the
members of this committee to look at the
code of conduct whether it's this
booklet or the ed510 on our
website as these are really focused on
child safety
issues representative uh
Morton thank you chair and thank thank
you for your testimony uh attorney um so
my sister's been a teacher for 35 years
two of our grandparents were Educators
for more than 40 years my grand father
was the superintendent of marac Valley
Schools opened the school in
1967 so I'm very much pro-education I
just want to make sure everyone here
understands that um I I just have a
question is this going to help
streamline your
procedures thank you for the question
and uh I'm happy to hear you come from a
family of Educators um very briefly my
mom was a special ed teacher here in New
Hampshire and when I called her and told
her I was going to law school she said
but wait I hate those people
um and and and not much has changed
since so um thank you to your family for
for all their work the short answer is
yes it will help to streamline it
because the department has been
successful in navigating these cases but
it hasn't always been the straightest
line and so this really is a tool in the
toolbox this is not meant to disrupt or
affect our really good strong working
relationships with the field we value
those and I cannot cannot emphasize that
enough this is not to go pounding around
and showing and flexing off our muscle
this is a
tool for those horrible cases that we
read about in the paper where the
department says we need to proceed and
obtain this person's
credential representative Manos thank
you Mr Vice chair and thank you for
taking my question attorney Fenton um is
it correct that you uh finalized a rule
making recently and if so do any of the
rules um affect due process in the
context of this bill that we're working
on thank you very much for the question
that was in my notes to address and I
failed to do so so I appreciate you
bring that to my attention as I
mentioned the ed5 11s which handle our
due process piece of how we implement
the code of conduct those were recently
redone and they were finalized um I want
to say June 17th of 2024 I know someone
in mid June they were finalized and
adopted and again you can find those on
our website we redid those um because we
realized that the rules that we had
originally drafted uh were insufficient
we needed to strengthen them we needed
to make them better and I'm humble
enough to say I drafted the first
version realized that we needed to make
it better and I drafted the second
version with our with our stakeholder
Partners nowhere in the Ed 511s does it
talk about
subpoenas it talks about the
investigative process and notifying a
credential holder that they are under
investigation notifying the
superintendent of the employing school
district that an individual is under
investigation and what the hearing looks
like representative B uh
beron trying to think of my question um
it's okay thanks I decided not to ask
you that's okay representative trip
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh it appears that uh while you're able
to get all the information that you want
from the school districts uh there may
be some uh
hesitancy
uh would it be true to say that uh
having subpena power would uh make them
much more
compliant that's that's certainly The
Hope in in the first instance we don't
want to have to use that
power but the reality is as I mentioned
earlier and and you gave me a very nice
short answer to give you and being the
lawyer I am I'm going to just add to it
the reality is there are times where we
need that subpoena power and and I
cannot emphasize enough how much we
value our working relationships but yes
there have been times where where we
might need that tool in the toolbox
thank you representative Smith thank you
very much if in fact this bill were to
pass um would that mean that you would
now have the
authority to ask
contractors with whom you have entered
into um a professional relationship to
share with you uh detailed inform
information about how they in fact
um
uh uh acquire and
expend public
funds I
don't as you well know and everyone
knows you do not have to answer any
question that we
ask I actually didn't know that I
you learn something new every day um
we'll just subpoena
you perfect I I've been there before let
me tell you um thank you for the
question I was a little surprised by the
question because that's not what this
bill is intended for this bill is
intended for violations of the code of
conduct it is envisioned to handle
investigations of Educators who might
have harmed a child so I cannot Envision
a a a situation and certainly it it
would fall outside of of my purview it
would fall outside of the code of
conduct and I think the way the stat the
the proposed bill is written it is
narrowly tailored to allow the
department to effectuate the power
that's already been given by this
legislative body in 21
and9 and much to representative Lynn's
point it's frustrating at times this
state agency to have been given this
authority to
oversee licensing and make sure children
are safe and not be given all the tools
in which to do it so I thank you for
your consideration I thank you for your
time I hope I've answered all the
questions and I see that I have
not representative
beron I I'm sorry Morton opposite ends
uh so so real quick question is a
followup to the other question if it's
cutting um you know the procedural time
would it then be neutral or do you think
it um it would save the taxpayers money
because it would be a cost cutting
saving or savings measure as well
because you're spending less time
chasing after
information I I I certainly hope that at
the end of the day that it it helps to
save time and if that helps to save
taxpayer money of course the agency
wants to do that
absolutely representative Manos thank
you Mr Vice chair and thank you again
for taking my question um I believe and
please correct me that the Attorney
General would have advised the
Department of Education on its Ru making
on its Rec recent rule making and I'm
wondering
why doe would not have included subpoena
power um in their revised
rules thank you for the question
um I wrote The Ed 511s originally as I
me and I wrote the redraft that was
adopted um June of 2024 I'm sure the
Attorney General's office might have
been aware of that but that is really a
function of the state agency
um I don't recall having in-depth
conversations with the Attorney
General's office about that rul making
piece obviously the other attorney who
represents the Board of Education would
be aware of that but there was no wasn't
an in-depth
well let me think
um the other attorney who represents the
the Department of Education and is
connected with the Attorney General's
office was aware of our rulemaking was
aware of Ed
511 um but to your point why subpoena
power wasn't put in there is because the
department at this time does not have
the does not have that Authority if we
don't have the authority we can't put it
in our Ru making and if we put it in our
Ru making it would have been flagged by
OS and we wouldn't have been able to
move forward with
it any other
questions seeing none thank you wait you
all set representative Berger on you I
know I'm a little obsessed with this
school district thing but
um do you ever find that school
districts actually have to contact the
Department of Education if they have
information before you
do as far as okay so that's one thing I
was just kind of curious how that
communication goes back and forth so it
could be driven from both then okay oh
absolutely and in fact usually the
information comes from the school
district right okay they're kind of the
charter schools as well because
sometimes they have one they one school
oh absolutely I
mean we have good working relationships
with the field and and I think field
there there are times where the field
and the department can be at odds but
the reality is this when it comes to
child safety everyone's on the same page
there is not a school district or a Char
school or a superintendent or a
principal who is not going to be up in
arms when it's about child safety and
making sure that educators are
appropriate around kids I have never met
anyone in the field who says to me oh
well yeah no big deal everyone is on the
same page and the department is so proud
of those working relationships because
we are all moving in the same direction
on this issue there might be other
political issues that divide us but not
this not when it comes to child safety
and it is for that reason that we have
strong
Partnerships any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you again for your time and
consideration thank you David Trumble
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members my name is David Trumble I'm
from the town of where I oppose this
bill is it is written I would agree with
the last words of the last speaker
everyone is on the same page when it
comes to child safety the only question
with this bill is subpoenas who should
issue them and what should be the legal
standard I believe the standard should
be first it should be done by uh who is
it should be done by the attorney
general and two is the standard should
be good cause let's look at how this is
handled with other agencies in the State
Communications common carriers if they
need a subpoena it goes to the attorney
general that's RSA
76b charitable trusts goes to the
attorney general RSA
724 consumer protection act RSA 358a
goes to the attorney general Department
of Health and Human Services 170e goes
to the attorney general in fact 170e
deal deals with child care residential
care and child placing agencies and it
involves specifically disciplinary
hearings which is exactly the case
you're looking at here today and in that
situation they require the Department of
Health and Human Services to go to the
attorney general and they have to have
good cause that's the standard we use
elsewhere in the statutes in New
Hampshire not the standard that you're
getting in front of you today as for
what do other states do I looked to
online and the only thing I could find
was a thorough report called the
administrative subpoena Authority
written by the national District
Attorneys Association which reviewed
laws in all 50 states it's a 195 page
report there are no education
Commissioners who have independent
subpoena power in the United States so
the standard I believe should be go to
the attorney general and they should
have to get good cause and good cause is
a legal phrase that has significance if
you look up The subpoena world there's
court cases that Define good cause
there's law reviews that Define good
cause it's more than the the low bar
that is in in the bill that is written
in front of you um I'd like to look at
uh what the statute requires first of
all it requires the hearings officer
shall issue this subena if they meet two
conditions first it's a possible
violation of the code of conduct and
second that it's reasonably likely to be
relevant well as was testified to
earlier the code of conduct has gone
beyond credentialing it's gone beyond
child safety it is now unfortunately
gone into the culture wars so what this
bill would do is permit subpoenas on a
whole broad range of issues which was
not the intent of the bill nor is it the
issue of child safety as for reasonably
likely to be relevant anything would be
reasonably likely to be relevant on any
of these bills whether or not a teacher
is teaching what are they teaching in
Black History Month what are they
teaching in women's History Month all of
those could be suspect under some of the
bills that have been put forward by this
legislature in the last couple of years
so you have a very broad range of
bills every lesson plan for every social
studies teacher in the state could be
subpoenaed because they could possibly
be a violation of the code of conduct
and they certainly would be reasonably
likely uh to be relevant I'd like to
just go back to a couple things attorney
Fenton said three of them first the
attorney said the the uh that the
Attorney General defers to the agencies
to do their own oversight that's fine
the question is not does the doe do its
own oversight it's who issues The
subpoena the Attorney General would not
come into the due and conduct a hearing
no the question is not who conducts the
hearing it's who gets to do the
subpoenas the question then came up well
can the Attorney General get us a Pena
for an agency and the Attorney General
said no of course they're going to say
no because right now it's not in the
statute but I gave you four other
statutes where they are specifically
obligated to get this subance so the
answer could be if you make make it such
you could fix this statute have the
Attorney General do it lastly was there
an example of an of a hearing in the
conquered case again the Attorney
General subpoena would solve that there
is no example where the Attorney General
subpoena won't solve it so then the
question is why am I here today why do I
want the Attorney General to do it
rather than the Department of Education
to do it and what concerns me is the
chilling effect of this bill if teachers
believe that there will be subpoenas ISS
ued as to whether or not they are
teaching black history in a certain way
and and there will be subpoenas they
will avoid teaching it and we will
produce a generation of children who
don't understand the history because
teachers will just avoid teaching the
way you
avoid having a negative impact on our
state's education is just to Simply to
say for this bill send it over to the
attorney general have the Attorney
General do it have them do it with good
cause then you don't have this chilling
effect on good education in our in our
state um I think that covers everything
I had to say okay thank you sir thank
you I have a question so of the agencies
you spoke of when you first started
testifying how many of those agencies
where the Attorney General Files The
subpoena um have disciplinary hearings
for lenses or
certified uh
employees uh or is it the case that they
are filing these subpoenas for
violations of a certain statute that
those agencies cover so like with the
Department of Health and Human Services
example that was specifically for a
disciplinary hearing that's uh RSA 170e
section 41 the department uh talks about
disciplinary hearings and they go to the
attorney general for Good Cost shown to
subpoena Witnesses and compel papers and
Records in any disciplinary hearing
under that subdivision so that's
specific to disciplinary hearings um I
didn't print out the other statutes I
looked at them this morning I I'm pretty
sure the charitable trust one is pretty
broad uh and again it's trying to
protect the public so I I sorry I don't
have those other three statutes in front
of me okay so but as far as somebody
that works for the Department of Health
and Human Services is there specifically
for their certifications or their
licenses oh I understand understand okay
no okay this this this is uh I I believe
this would be for cases where there's a
disciplinary hearing for somebody who
works in child care residential care or
child placing agencies if there's a
disciplinary hearing it's a little
different than a certification but that
goes back to the question of
certification if certification is simply
um a child safety issue everybody agrees
the hearing should be conducted you
should get your subpoena swiftly put it
in the law if if it's a child safety
issue have the Attorney General do it
they can do it very quickly they're
lawyers that's what they do for work and
there's a specific rule for lawyers it's
rule 4.5 of the code of conduct for
lawyers a lawyer shall not issue or
obtain the issuance of a subpoena
without good cause so they know how to
issue subpoenas if there's a child
safety issue by all means the Attorney
General can get it quickly for you okay
any other
questions representative Smith thank you
do you have a a written copy of your
testimony I do I will I will submit it
if you don't have copy for everyone
could you at least give it to the clerk
and I have one extra copy I'll give only
one thank you any other questions
representative
bur uh thank you for your testimony
leaving aside the issue of uh the AG's
office versus doe running the show just
talking about the issue of code of
conduct um would you find this a better
Bill if everywhere the term code of
conduct was changed to to language
specifically limiting to
credentialing and eliminate the language
of code of conduct uh thank you for the
question representative I am not sure
could you just to give me a little bit
more to go on there like what what is it
that you're trying to get at I'm not
sure I quite get it my question to you
is we've heard a lot of testimony from
you and others that the code of conduct
would allow investigations into an
almost unlimited area of
teaching if code of conduct were removed
from the statute and instead or the bill
and instead the bill only allowed these
subpoenas for questions of
credential would that solve the problem
or is credential itself open up the door
too wide uh I understand better thank
you for the question I don't think you
can separate it out because the code of
conduct is what the the teachers have to
follow and that's where the hearing is
going to
be um I think the distinction rather
than credentialing a quote of conduct is
it's if it's it's a safety issue that's
that's where everybody immediately wants
to get the Attorney General it's it's
the issue is really as somebody said
other committees are are studying bills
and passing bills that have expanded
what used to be understood as the code
of conduct to being a broad thing
because they're looking for how do we
enforce this and put some punitive
action on the teacher so they say oh
okay we'll just put in it's you don't do
this law now you violated the code of
conduct so the code of conduct is now
expanded to include how do you teach a
certain lesson plan so but you can't you
could shrink the code of conduct down to
a reasonable size but I don't think you
can take it out of this because that's
where the hearings come from is would
have but in the old days legitimate
issues on Code of Conduct does that it
make sense yeah okay thank you any other
questions representative
trip uh are you representing your
yourself or an organization I I just
here as a citizen yeah right thank
you representative Horgan um you're
talking about expanding the code of
conduct um will we be we be isn't there
like an example of that um actually
right across the hall about 12 feet from
the door to this room with a uh non
gered amendment to a bill which actually
ironically is there relevance this
question so I just that isn't that just
one example of attempts to expand the
code of Contex yes thank you
representative Oran he's exactly right
that's the the device of Concepts Bill
there was a bill presented to repeal it
and then there's another amendment today
so that's exactly the issue here is like
can you get a subpoena to make sure that
people are teaching divisive Concepts
correctly according to what you consider
correctly I think that's the concern
here is it's it's not defending teachers
it's because teachers are just
implements to educate our children I'm
concerned about the children who won't
get an education if they're afraid to
talk about issues because they're afraid
they're going to lose their license and
if you make subpoenas too broad you
reduce
education any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you sir Deborah house
okay yes good morning my name is Deborah
how I am president of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire uh
we represent about
3,500 Educators and School staff across
the state of New Hampshire as well as uh
College faculty and town employees and
uh we are here in opposition to HB 520
and it's not because we are not
concerned about children being safe in
our schools we absolutely believe that
is necessary and support the code of
conduct what we don't support is
subpoena power for the Department of
Education even if it's done through
hearing officers um we feel that this
bill is a solution in search of a
problem as we have heard the past two
times we've have hearings on this and
even again repeated today the department
is able to get the information it needs
we heard it very clearly stated uh from
a previous testifier they can get the
information they need even in that
horrible case she mentioned here in
conquer they got the information they
needed had to go to the outside attorney
that was hired by the uh School District
but they were able to get the
information they needed and they got the
result they needed as well so why do we
need this bill the department
investigator testified that they are
always able to get the information they
need we are keeping Kids Safe using the
investigatory processes that are in
place this is an unnecessary bill um it
would it
would unbalance the current system we're
using if we put this in place and um put
the weight more heavily on the
investigatory side you would not have
the same power to subpoena as someone
who is being accused of breaking the
code of conduct at the same time so
there are timelines in place
and uh as someone who is suddenly
accused of having broken the code of
conduct you would not have the same
amount of time to gather information to
defend yourself and as um Mr Hawkins
from Nea um testified there's only a
limited amount of time to prepare your
defense of that accusation before a
hearing occurs so you would be um at a
disadvantage before you're presented
with what the results the department
wants at that hearing so that would be
unfair to uh have that occur uh my other
point besides the fact that this is a um
solution search of a problem is the
safeguards in this bill although they
look nice on paper um having the hearing
officer who works for the Department of
Education apply the test of whether the
um subpoena is being sought in good
faith and whether it's material for aena
being asked for by his
boss I'm a labor leader if the boss asks
you to do something at least in your
mind you know you're going to tend to
agree with them even if you know you
have all good intentions to view it
impartially it's going to be very hard
to be
impartial and there's all sorts of room
for there to be undue pressure that's
not a great standard the previous
speaker told you of other um agencies
other
um departments that have
the have the Attorney General issues to
be this specifically Health and Human
Services has it for investigations uh in
child care settings uh that are are very
similar to what you're talking about
here child safety that would be a more
appropriate place to go for a subpoena
because we do want to keep kids safe and
we also don't want
to poison the relationship between our
department of education and our school
districts who need to cooperate on these
investigations or between the Department
of Education and our Educators who are
out there working with their children
every day we don't want to be a climate
of
fear we want everyone to be open and
sharing information because we do all
have the same goal of keeping Kids Safe
making sure that they are learning and
thriving and I do have written testimony
to share but I do think that this bill
is unnecessary because we are
getting that job done already with the
tools that we have this is an
unnecessary tool thank you any
questions seeing none thank you I
apologize for not having stap it I
thought I had double-sided it that's
fine Barrett is it Christina Christian
Christina
thank you Mr chair good morning members
of the committee my name is Barett
Christina I am the executive director of
the New Hampshire school boards
Association to be clear the school
boards Association is not taking a
position on this bill but we do want to
identify a couple concerns that we uh
that we have with with the language
itself um I'll make a couple points
about the bill um and then I will make a
couple broader policy uh as points as
well too I'll try and be brief
recognizing we've been on this bill for
a little bit more than an hour and a
half um the first I'm on page one um
lines 3 through six where it says that
um a subpoena may be issued against any
person um nhsb has concerns if that may
be too broad does that just mean School
District staff or the individual who is
under investigation or could have
possibly be um an a subpoena issued
against a student who perhaps was a
witness to something or perhaps even
more concerning um the spouse or partner
of of the licensed educator who may or
may not have relevant information to
whatever in in in investigation is going
on we have concerns that that is a
little bit too broad um the second
aspect um that nhba has concerns with
with the bill um I'm on um page one
again lines 24 and 25 the person to whom
the subpoena is directed May file a
motion to quash or modify the subpoena
with the hearings officer it's the
hearings officer who's issuing The
subpoena uh I find it curious that the
individual who um would possibly quash
The subpoena is also the individual who
who who issued it that may be common um
in other areas of law I simply don't
know um but it seems to be that there
should be um the appeal or or the motion
of qua should be um uh provided to an
independent third party rather than the
person who is doing the
investigation um and last um
representative ber you you pointed this
out that while the license holder um
does have an opportunity to subpoena
documents or or whatnot during the
adjudicatory stage they don't have an
opportunity to do so under this bill
relative to the um the investigatory
stage which nhsb nhba believes would be
um the most important aspect of the of
of the timelines um second um a broader
aspect to the bill when nhba was
testifying on the bill um uh two
sessions ago and the proposed amendment
two sessions ago um nsba suggested that
um guard rails and safe safeguards be
put in place for students and Student
Records um unfortunately um House Bill
520 um still does not contain those if a
subpoena is going to be issued for
Student Records that are otherwise
exempt from disclosure under state and
federal law we believe that there should
be some guard rails put in the statute
as to who at the department is going to
have access to those how long the
department is going to retain those at
what point is the department going to
destroy those student records um we also
have concerns um about a child being
subpoena and then the parents having to
go through the rig roll of filing a
motion to get a quashed before the
hearings officer um the other aspect too
I guess relative to the to the to the um
to a child being subpoena there's no
sort of enforcement mechanism in the
statute if I'm a parent and my child is
subpoena and I read the bill and I'm
perhaps given notice in The subpoena
that I have 10 days to file an appeal if
I'm a parent and I don't show up and I
don't bring my kid to
testify what's the department going to
do about it am I facing some sort of
criminal penalty as a parent because I
don't want my child talking to an
investigator at the Department of
Education the bill is not clear about
that so those are our concerns with the
statute itself I'm sorry the the bill
itself a couple points to the larger um
broader policy aspects by way of
background I served on the uh committee
that drafted the code of conduct back in
2018 the primary focus of that committee
in that group as Miss Fenton repeatedly
stated was child safety the health
safety and Welfare of children and we
reached Great Compromise through the
teachers unions through people from
higher education School administrators
School boarders Association and the
Department of Education to come up with
a really good document that everybody
was happy with and everybody thought met
the needs um to keep children safe it's
important to remember that two sessions
ago when the first subpoena bill was
brought forth to this committee
it had absolutely nothing to do with
child safety it had to do with what
books were being taught in public
schools and as Mr Hawkins um spoke about
during his testimony we've had a
plethora of bills last session and this
session seeking to broaden um impacts of
the of the of the teacher code of
conduct that have absolutely nothing to
do with child safety and are far beyond
what the original purpose and intent and
Good Will created out of that committee
was was with the current code of conduct
it had to do with books had nothing to
do with child safety so with that I'll
close my remarks I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you for taking my
testimony are there any questions
representative
Tura yeah thank you thanks for taking
the question um it came up in the
earlier testimony by other um witnesses
that um other departments go through the
Attorney General's office for subpoenas
um and it seems in the list that you um
laid out here that many of those those
things could be handled by the
discretion of the Attorney General if
they um were the entity that that was
being sought um would would it be your
understanding that that would clear up
some or or many of the questions that
you've raised yeah thank you for the
question representative um I know that's
been part of the conversation over the
last couple of bills that we've had
relative to this I did hear one of the
previous speakers suggest that um during
his testimony I kind of nodded to myself
and thought that might be a reasonable
alternative thank you any other
questions representative
Smith um could you tell me if you are
aware of any
um situation in which your
organization would have advised um
uh your constituents not to cooperate at
with the uh Department of Education
thank you for the question
representative um just to clarify our
constituents are school boards and
school board members um school boards
are typically not involved in employee
matters or employee investigations those
are usually handled administratively
through principles and
superintendence um I'm trying to think
if I've had occasion to speak to a a a a
school board member about that no um
nothing coming to mind we've certainly
over the years had inquiries from school
superintendents where they're not
certain if they should report something
to the Department of Education or
they're not certain if it's a violation
of the code of conduct Our advice is
call the commissioner or call Miss
Fenton and and flush it out that way I
mean it's not my job as an attorney to
tell you not to report something if you
report something and the department
doesn't need to go any further there's
no harm no foul if you don't report
there are significant
consequences thank you any other
question question s seeing none thank
you thank
you that's the last card I have for
House Bill 520 is there anyone else that
wants to speak on
it seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
520 and I'm going to open up the hearing
on House Bill 188 relative to contempt
of the general court and I
recognize representative Lynn to
introduce the bill
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee
um as
um as those of you who were here in past
uh in in the past legislative session
may remember there was um a rather
unfortunate incident that developed not
in this committee fortunately but
involving um the issuance or the or the
attempted issuance of uh a subpoena to
uh
Witnesses um coming before the
legislature that resulted in quite a Kur
fuffle um
uh and it was really I I think a very
unfortunate situation but one of of the
things that developed as a result of
that was the question of well was the
whole question of
issuing
subpoenas can that be done and there is
a in the existing rule there is a
provision that that um that talks about
that but there was a question of then
what you know is there any law on this
is there any is there any statute is
there any law what um what
uh what's the consequence if a subpoena
is ISS and if it's not complied with and
that kind of thing so um the um there
was a
uh a group of people who got together
and the the in particular the speaker
and the deputy speaker uh asked me if I
would take a stab at
drafting um legislation to cover that um
and I I undertook some research and I
and I and what I and 188 is sort of the
product of that um of that effort and um
it basically
establishes both a civil and a and a
criminal penalty for someone who is
subpoenaed and there are you know in the
in the rule it's uh there there are very
limited circumstances including which
requires the the approval of the whole
house and requires uh the concurrence of
the speaker in the in the in the current
rule as I would call it before a
subpoena can be issued this statute
doesn't deal with the issuing of
subpoena of the subpoenas as such but it
deals with what happens if somebody
fails to comply what what can the
legislature do to compel
compliance and during the course of my
research on this um what what I um what
I discovered is that
even without is that there's no there is
no law in New Hampshire on this there
are a number of of other um of states
that do have laws on this and in
particular I I took uh the the sort of
generally the format for this from a
federal statute um dealing with contempt
of contemp of Congress this is not
exactly the same as that statute but it
it does incorporate a number of elements
of it um at any rate one of the things
that I discovered in the course of that
research is that there is some Authority
there's no New Hampshire Authority on
this and I'm not really sure how many
other states have authority on it but
there is some at the federal level there
is some Authority that basically says
that Congress that a legislative body
has the inherent
authority to
um uh both compel people to appear uh
before it via subpoena and if they fail
to do that to punish them so for for
example there you know in uh many in the
in the long in the long past um there
were a number of instances and as I my
the research uh that I recall the last
time it happened at the federal level
was about I think in
1914 where the Congress uh or a
committee of the of the um of the of one
house or the other with the approval of
the of the of the Congress
uh actually sent the sergeant-at-arms
out uh to arrest somebody who had failed
to comply with an order to appear um and
um uh you know so that
that inherent
authority of the legislature arguably
would allow us to do that too I don't
think that we've ever done it I'm not
suggesting that we ever would want to
consider doing it but apparently there
is some at least arguably there's some
inheritance authority to do that but one
of the things that that prompted this
bill was you a number of people said
well you know wait a minute I mean if we
ever actually got to that point do we
should we just sort of leave it up to
like you know we'll we'll we'll decide
whether we want to have to send send the
sergeant-at-arms out um uh to to arrest
somebody and then one once they once
they arrest them what do we do did they
bring them to court what uh what happens
so the the the question is you without
this with without this legislation we
can just leave it and play it by ear and
you know hope that uh if it in in the
unfortunate situation that that that
that ever happened we'll will'll you
know we'll play it by ear what we do and
presumably we would be the courts would
be playing and at least in New Hampshire
would be playing it by ear in terms of
what they do or does it make sense to
have a procedure specifying what happens
and that's what this bill attempts to do
um as you'll see by reading it it's you
know it it has a whole lot of of uh
conditions that have to that have to
exist before uh the either the criminal
penalty or the Civil uh enforcement
procedure can um Can arise it has to it
requires you know the uh that that the
house or the senate or if it's joint
both bodies uh determin that the person
is in in contempt that they had no basis
for failing you know for failing to
comply and there would have to be a a a
vote by the entire bodies to to do that
and then it would go to the courts and
the courts again would have an
opportunity to to uh to review that
judgment and determine whether there was
a valid basis for failing to comply uh
this the the criminal penalty that is uh
is provided is you know it's a
misdemeanor it's it's not uh particular
significant uh penalty and the Civil uh
penalty uh uh provides that provides
that uh there could be a finding of
civil contempt and um a an order that
the you know at the most extreme in the
Civil context would be an order that the
person be incarcerated until they comply
that's the typical civil contempt uh
remedy um so with that um hope you know
hopefully
this if this became the law it would
never come into play because we' never
we'd never get to that stage but I
suppose it it's better to have it there
than not have it there that would be my
my sense on I'm happy to answer any
questions are there any questions
representative
bur thank you Mr chair and and thank you
for your explanation um I I personally
tend to agree about the inherent powers
but we'll put that aside my question to
you is the operation of the on the
criminal offense only um understanding
the Civil remedies are are fairly
traditional so in line four we have what
I'll call the wandering uh concept of
knowingly and uh folks understand that
knowingly uh is a certain state of mind
and uh um but when we get down to
line8 it's simply you're wrong you
didn't have a good reason whether it's
knowingly or not um and then you can be
found guilty of a misdemeanor so my
first question is is has knowingly
dropped out of the
consideration uh in this uh I in the
section I'm not you know what I I I
don't I'm not sure I understand it
certainly was I think the knowingly my
my intention was that it applied to you
have to act knowingly but I'm not quite
sure I understand where you're saying it
you have a question about whether it
would apply well in line 8 to
nine uh or who having
appeared refuses to answer any question
or produce any books my question is is
that a knowing
refusal at that time uh with an
explanation sure sure I mean I think I I
yes I think knowingly does apply I mean
it's
hard I think certainly the knowingly
would I I would intended that to apply
there but I I guess what I would I guess
what I would say
is it you know I I it's hard to imagine
how somebody
refusing would not be that you don't
know you're refusing I mean I that
particularly where it says without just
cause so if you I mean but if somebody
asks you somebody asks you a question
and you refuse to answer it's hard to
you know I mean I certainly did intend
it to be no I suppose somebody could
accidentally refuse but that would be
you know and and what are the
consequences of the guilty of a
misdemeanor is there punishment to be
followed thereafter are there limits on
that
punishment well would I it it would be a
misdemeanor you'll notice it doesn't say
a Class A misdemeanor so I suppose it
could be um it I I I think it would be
subject to the um the the other law
which would say since it this presumably
is not a violent this is not a violent
offense so unless the the
prosecutor uh gave notice that they
intended it to be treated as a Class A
misdemeanor it would be a Class B
misdemeanor
and the consequences of followup
followup and the consequences other than
on your record of a Class B misdemeanor
would be limited to what class Class B
misdemeanor there's no jail time I think
where the fine is uh is it I I think
it's $1,200 is the maximum fine unless
it it may have changed since I was was
more intimately familiar with that but I
it's no jail time I think it's $1,200
maximum fine thank you representative
tur yeah thank you and thanks for the
question uh taking the question
um I guess I'm wondering from what I
understood from the incident last year
and from your
opening uh committees by themselves in
New Hampshire can't issue subpoenas
without going through the general court
that's that's what I I mean first of all
I never thought about until this whole
incident
issued you know the idea of issuing
subpoenas for was never something that
was on my radar screen right I I think
that that that you are right but
apparently there you know there
was a not insubstantial group of people
who didn't share that view of uh um so
I'll can I do fall um yeah so uh and my
understanding is that that you're not
trying to either to clarify that in any
way this is this is basically what
happens if someone doesn't follow
exactly exact this is not this doesn't
you'll notice there's no reference to
subpoena anywhere in here it's just it's
about is referenced online well I'm no
I'm sorry I'm sorry in terms of in terms
of how when a subpoena should be issued
or anything like that it's what happens
if you don't if it is issued and you
don't comply so one more one more follow
sorry um so I guess what what I'm
wondering is the way it's worded like uh
on line five it says you know comply
with a subpoena duly issued and served
um by either House of the general court
I'm wondering all the stuff after it
seems to imply that that committees do
have subpoena power sort of uh by
reference under under this this larger
statement I'm wondering does that all
need to be there because it seems to
confuse the issue rather than just
saying a subpoena duly issued by either
House of the General Court does that
point does that is that clear what I you
know no it is but you know what I I I
took this part of the language I did
take from the federal statute I think
it's no 2 USC something um um and I and
I think the the language you know it it
you're right it is long you know there's
a lot of different Clauses a joint
committee and that I took out of the
federal statute because I think it's it
it's designed to kind of
capture a number of situations in other
words a CO a committee of the house or a
committee of the senate or a joint
committee if there were such a committee
but I think all of the the the critical
language is subpoena duly issued so that
I think what that what that which really
I think applies to everything that
follows so that the whether the subpoena
was duly issued is did it was it issued
in in a accordance with the rules of
either the house or the senate or if it
was a joint committee presumably the
rules of both
bodies yeah to to just just clarifying I
I I that's what I was wondering is is
this some I don't know whether there is
something that spells out what's a duly
issued subpoena by the general court or
or either either body but it feels like
adding all that extra language seems to
imply a definition of of all that which
I wasn't sure was consistent with the
rule that may or may not exist for doing
that I well I don't I mean I don't think
it I don't I don't think that it I don't
think that it does do that I think it
just basically it it all the all the
language after duly issued is B
basically designed to cover you know
what the what the uh what the subpoena
if it was duly issued might might cover
like a subpoena for Testimony or
subpoena for books or documents or
records and what who would be issuing it
would be you know I mean what in what
proceeding was it issued in connection
with a house a house committee a senate
committee a joint committee maybe the
full body of either one I I suppose it
would it could cover any of those but in
terms of
whether you know the the prerequisite
that is a duly issued subpoena that
would depend on the rules and I I do
agree with you that right now the rule
at least the rules of the house
are you know let me let me put they
could be clearer than they are that's
for sure
um any other questions representative
Manos thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you for taking my question I wanted to
um discuss lines 13 and 14 and also line
26 and I wasn't clear on you have
failure to comply as being a
misdemeanor excuse me but then a
prosecution would be in the superior
court for maram County right and I was
confused about why a misdemeanor would
specifically go to the Superior Court
rather than the circuit court and then I
also wanted to ask about line 26 and the
potential conflict between a criminal
prosecution being in the circuit Court
um versus civil being in the superior
court so basically what I what I
intended to do with both of these is to
to limit the place where the prosecution
be could be brought and limit the
prosecutor so for the in the criminal
case it it it it I that was an
intentional decision to make even though
it's a misdemeanor to make it have to be
prosecuted in the Superior Court uh
because you know this uh this is this
would be an unu such a prosecution would
be a very unusual procedure it seems to
me it would be better to have such a pro
such a prosecution to be in the Superior
Court since it would have to you know
since it would involve the legislature
which sits un conquered marac County
limiting it to marac County seemed to me
to be another way to circumscribe this
and also requiring that it not be that
if it that the proc ution if it's going
to be undertaken would be undertaken by
the Attorney General's office rather
than a county attorney all of those
things are designed to kind of
limit to recognize that this would be a
in some sense an extraordinary
prosecution and for those reasons should
be limited to where it's brought who can
bring it and what court is
in follow um then would it not make more
sense for it to be for for violation to
be a felony rather than a
misdemeanor well uh I mean I I guess I
would say you
know I I would say no I would say that
you don't want
to I mean it it seems to me that the
light that the kind of situation we're
talking about here of somebody being
held in contempt of the legis you know
of the of the general court
very very rare if ever you know we're
going to see such a situation and if
there was one my inclination would be
that that the the the prospect of being
convicted of a
misdemeanor um which arguably could turn
into a Class A misdemeanor where it
would be up to a year in jail that would
be enough deterrence to uh to uh get the
job done so I would be opposed to making
it anything more harsh than that
representative
thank you very much could you tell me
how this relates to rule 28 of uh the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
rules it well I I think what the way it
relates is
this rule 28 has a procedure I mean I I
assume that I assume I don't have the
rules in front of me but I assume 28 is
the one that talks about subpoenas is
that am I correct on that yes it's it's
relevant right right no no no so I I
think I think what what the way it
relates is this this
statute says what happens if the s a
subpoena issued pursuant to that rule is
served and somebody doesn't comply with
the subpoena right now the rule doesn't
say anything about it that says you know
it talks about when a subpoena can be
issued and it doesn't say that that's
where it ends so is issued under the
rule okay now what happens could I have
one followup y uh thank you very much um
I asked uh because of the thoughtful
question that our colleague
representative tur raised um I um am I
incorrect in saying that the house rules
say that a subpoena can be issued only
by a vote of the Full House and that
would be act one so to speak in this
drama and then act two is if there was a
failure to comply but act one is already
in our house rules is that not true oh
no no that I I think that's right I
think as I said I I think I would read
rule 28 the same way that you and
representative tur rule read rule
28 some people apparently had a very
different View of what rule how rule 28
should be read but I think I agree with
you I I think you're right but I I think
what that whole incident
raised you know I I suppose maybe you
know there's a there's a um there's a
gray of sunlight in every uh in in every
cloudy situation um is the what okay so
let's assume that we we we actually get
to the position of issuing a subo
and somebody doesn't comply then what
happens and that's what this is designed
to could I be in one more short one you
don't you could say no you know no you
can you can certainly do that you could
say no to me um I think you know Mr
chair that I uh resist always uh
references to People by party and making
considerations by party but I must uh
ask you is there a reason why there is
one senator listed um as a sponsor but
there are no Democrats in the house or
the Senate is this perceived to be
something that is of concern only to
Republicans in the
house well I mean it's
certainly the the generation of this and
the you know I talked about the the
speaker and the deputy speaker and
myself I mean the generation of this um
uh was C certainly something that was
talked about in my caucus and my caucus
was the one that um proposed this um and
so that that was you know I just no I no
but I think no it's a legitimate
question I I I frankly did not um and I
and and I think that the I I I assume
that this is true of the speaker and the
deputy speaker didn't you know didn't
think to to to ask uh members of the of
the other party and I I
yeah any other questions representative
Burch just a quick question of
clarification uh based on your your
response to representative monos the the
prosecution by the Department of Justice
would that be
discretionary with the Department of
Justice to bring it or is that mandatory
because the house has taken a certain
action I think I there's nothing no
language I don't I don't think that the
Le the legislature could compel the
executive branch to bring a prosecution
um we might be really upset if they
didn't maybe that would have some effect
on their budget but I don't think that
we could I don't think that we could
compel the executive branch to bring a
prosecution thank you I just wanted to
make sure that was part of the right I
mean that's another reason to limit this
to the Department of Justice because it
it makes sure that you know it's not
going to be brought by a county attorney
if it's going to be brought at all it's
going to be the Department of Justice
thank you any other questions seeing
none thank you is there anybody else
just testifying on nobody I have no
other cards on this okay
good is there anyone else here that
wants to speak on House Bill
188 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
188 and we're going to open up the
hearing on House Bill 195 relative to
the expectation of privacy and the
collection and use of personal
information and I recognize
representative L to ruce that Bell thank
thank
you let you know what let me go check
I'll be
back representative Veron could you turn
off your microphone you're not speaking
great I heard you breathing
here but he's just
not
right all right sorry thank you Mr chair
members of the committee um there are
two bills that we've listed for hearing
that are are uh uh deal with privacy
195 is last year's House Bill 314
scene which passed the
house and
I somebody's gonna have to correct
representative Smith you may correct me
if I'm wrong I believe it it was it died
in the Senate that's my recollection is
that 314 died in the Senate
so my recollection again I stand to be
corrected by those of you who were here
last year is that 195
is the same bill as 314 last year and
that it passed this committee and pass
in the house on a bipartisan
basis um and what it was and still is
intended to do is to
be something of a supplement to Senate
Bill 255 which was the
broader privacy bill that was passed
um two years ago um and the
the the way that this bill differs from
255 is first of all this is a disclosure
bill it Deals Only with the disclosing
of information it doesn't unlike
255 it doesn't have really much to do
with the acquisition of information it's
only the disclosure of information and
it basically says that
for
um a
limited uh category of of uh
organizations referred to as third-party
providers of information and services
and the important thing to understand is
that in the definition of third-party
provider of information and services
that is
a narrower definition than the
definition of the of the various
businesses that would be covered by
255 it is um limited to um organizations
that collect uh information about a
person in connection with providing the
following kinds of
services um cellular and landline
telephone electric water uh other
utilities internet service providers
cable television streaming services
social media and uh service providers
Banks and financial institutions and
insurance companies and credit card
companies it's designed basically to
cover
those those kind of
Institutions rather
than more
broadly um all businesses which is or at
least all businesses of a certain size
which is what 255 cover and it basically
is designed to say if you you are one of
those covered
institutions then you can't
disclose personal
information um as defined in the um in
the statute um unless you have the
consent and the
consent has to be affirmative consent um
255 um
basically has sort of a
um an opt out for lack of a better term
an opt out feature that you can opt out
of of
uh having personal information
disclosed um but this bill provides more
protection in that it requires that you
affirmatively agree and that there's
requirements that it has to be um you
know can't be some getting your
affirmative agreement in some sort of
Nefarious way that you where you're not
likely to think about it's got to be an
affirmative you the communication is
sent to you do you consent to doing this
and you and you agree affirmatively to
do that so that's one way and then the
bill has a number of of uh of uh other
instances in which a some a covered
businesses can disclose
information um to uh
um Can disclo can disclose information
that is personal information in certain
circumstances and I want to uh in the
interest of of being brief I I I know
that there are other people that will be
testifying one of the things that that
someone expressed one of the sort of a
business an industry representative
expressed a concern to me about was
uh did the does the does the bill as
worded
allow um one of the covered entities to
disclose information if they have reason
to believe that there's been some
nefarious activity going on and and that
the person that talked to me was sort of
said they they were concerned that the
bill did not allow that I think that
that's not correct I think if you look
on the top of page two in Roman numeral
uh 507
I2 uh
1B uh it says that the third party
provider of information uh can disclose
information um if they have reason to
believe that such disclosure is
necessary to prevent detect protect
against or respond to past present or
expected criminal or fraudulent conduct
identity theft harassment or deceptive
or malicious activity so I think it is
designed to say that that can happen
you'll notice that the bill also has
specific provisions
dealing with the disclosure of personal
information at the request of
governmental entities and it again it'll
allows that to be done um but it it
contains requirements that have to be
satisfied um in order for that to be
done and I as I said this was um this
was something that I think was pretty
carefully car uh thought out by this
committee last year was approved on a
bipartisan basis and was approved by the
house and I think you know I think it is
a very reasonable bill and I hope uh
you'll support it and I'm happy to
answer any questions any
questions seeing none thank
you Neil
Kirk just
Che okay we'll hold his card
then okay
I'll hold his card uh Kirsten
Schultz good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Kiren Schultz I'm an attorney based in
Manchester uh with Nix and pey and I'm
here on behalf of State Farm which is
one of the leading writers of home and
auto insurance here in New Hampshire um
I'm here to note our concerns with with
HB 195 as drafted um I didn't expect to
go first I I just have some high level
concerns that I'll brief I'll briefly uh
tell you about and then I I expect there
are others here who may voice uh similar
concerns but we are primarily concerned
with the bill because it adds an
unworkable overlay to the already
complex landscape of privacy compliance
for insurance companies
um SB 255 or now enacted as RSA 507
which went into effect uh earlier this
year includes the exemptions relevant to
State Farm as an insurer um but this
bill fails to incorporate those same
exemptions um and the bill appears to
cause some conflicts with the existing
law and exemptions uh particularly with
respect to what we might Define as um
personal information or uh non-public
personal information or personally
identifying
information um the bill is um it could
be drafted better and more clearly um we
think that obviously it fails to take
into account those exemptions that are
in uh RSA
507 um we would be happy to work with uh
the committee to to try to redraft some
of the language if that's needed um and
we would respectfully note that the the
structure of this bill
with the opt-in framework is uh
different from what one tends to see in
other run-of-the-mill privacy bills here
and elsewhere um the opt-in consent
mechanism for the disclosure of personal
information is problematic for us for a
number of reasons um we would certainly
prefer to have an opt out mechanism
because that would uh from our
perspective lower compliance costs while
still empowering individuals with
decision- making a authority over how
their data is utilized and uh as um
chairman Lynn noted the uh RSA 507
H4 does contain that opt out framework
rather than opt in
um it uh under the bill as drafted the
process for seeking consent uh is
separate has to be separate from any
other communication sent to the
individual by the third party provider
of information and services and that
creat
uh a pretty big additional step for
State Farm anyway that would require
development of new forms and notices to
be implemented and that could also be
very
costly um in section proposed section
507 uh
I3 comma Roman 3 uh disclosure of
personal information to government
entities that requires um that a
provider must
contemporaneously with such a disclosure
to a governmental entity
provide notice that it has made that
disclosure to the individual to whom the
information pertains and again
contemporaneous disclosure is not very
practicable for a number of reasons and
we would propose considering uh possibly
increasing that time period or defining
the amount of allowable time to disclose
to the individual for example 30 to 45
business days um just as a
suggestion
um the bill does also put limitations on
sharing data obviously um you can't
share data with service providers
vendors Affiliates and uh the
problematic part of that um from a
practical perspective is that State Farm
as an insurance company often discloses
phone numbers to service providers um
even to other insurers in the course of
claim handling that goes on
frequently um and lastly I would say
just the enforcement mechanism that is
included in the bill has drafted
enforcements conducted by the AG's
office meaning that for State Farm it
would really add a whole another
regulator another another agency um and
it's also concerning that there is no
opportunity to cure an alleged violation
built into this bill before the ago uh
commences an enforcement action so those
are our high level thoughts on uh why we
think the bill is problematic as drafted
and we would oppose it happy to respond
to questions if necessary are there any
questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
muches do you have any
written do you have written testimony
for the committee I I have my notes I'm
happy to submit my notes later you like
great thank you okay thank
you lieutenant Steve is it mcau Mol mcau
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Lieutenant Steve
mcau I'm with the New Hampshire State
Police and representing the nire state
police um on House Bill
195 we are taking a neutral St stance
and uh this is really just educational
and just some of the two concerns that
we see with the bill as is um the first
one I wanted to address was on page
three line one uh where it states that
shall not require production of the
information sooner than 10 days from the
date the request or demand is made and
then within 5 days uh receiving such a
request or demand the provider shall
notify the individual who the
information pertains to uh the concern
we see with this is while we're in the
midst of investigating a crime
and with myself I'm the lieutenant of
the major crime unit and investigating
these arious crimes we're often
submitting subpoenas multiple subpoenas
looking for different records
uh this one addresses some about cell
phones um and that sort of type of
Records when we're issuing these
subpoenas oftentimes we need this
information back very quickly to be able
to continue our investigation on uh to
make it possibly make an arrest or
increased um P PC to get an arrest
warrant or to be able to locate a person
who is wanted for a a crime oftentimes
it's a very violent crime if the
production is not uh does not have to be
within 10 days that could delay us
getting this information to be able to
um enforce these crimes such as uh
homicide or whatever crime it may be
that this falls under uh as well as be
able to gain more probable cause towards
an an arrest warrant so this could cause
us some sort of delay in getting this
information um and then the notification
down on line 15 or 14 it starts it talks
about uh contemporar
notifying the I guess the customer that
this request has been made this causes a
concern for us as well under these
circumstances the 507 I3 IC primarily ID
and I which would be uh more of an
Exogen circumstance for us often times
these uh requests to these providers
under the exm circumstances are
requested prior to the primary
investigative team arriving to these
locations it may be requested from say a
911 operator like this outli or the
local police department may have a phone
number and they may request active pinks
on someone that say um somebody just
kidnapped two children and they're on
the Run they may request these uh pings
and this information through this and
then this states that
contemporaneously they need to notify
the
provider as you can see this would cause
an issue if we're trying to track
somebody that has committed a violent
crime or committed any crime that we're
able to enforce this type of activity
on but then they're notified that we're
currently looking for them and they're
notified that we're looking at their
cell phone uh location such and attempt
to locate them I I would imagine so this
would give them opportunity to then uh
further hide or shut up their phones or
um make it much more difficult for for
us to find them and then the possibility
of them committing whatever their final
plan was or act is um and maybe speed up
that
timeline those are our two concerns uh
primarily with House Bill uh 195 as it
reads representative
Smith thank thank you uh for being here
I'm I'm a little surpris I'm glad to see
you always glad to have people come um
but as I read the bill
um your issues that you raised are very
very important and you're exempt under
this bill from any of the restrictions
that you talked about I see it in um
well let's see the first place I see it
is
um well if you just start on page to
line 18 and you go on through all of
that and then
you also specifically on page three
starting with line nine um all of that
um would I think uh answer your quite
legitimate concerns that your situation
is unusual and
requires um immediate response am I
missing something
here as we read it um and if I do go on
to page three line nine like you state
it says when a government entity seeks
disclosure of personal information from
a provider of information and services
pursuant to RSA 507 I3 I uh 1C 1D or 1e
the provider shall contemporar inly with
such disclosure provide notice that it
has made the disclosure so I guess maybe
that's our confusion but I feel like
that states that um even if we make it
under the exent circumstance or under
the circumstances in 1 D or 1e it's
still going to notify or it's saying
that still shall contempor
notify uh the provider and then did you
go on to read the rest I don't blame you
if you don't this stuff gets very
boring are you talking about um I well
it it goes on and and it um so are so
and you go I mean it seems to me that
and I'm sorry it needs to be if it needs
to be clarified then I'm certainly glad
that you brought that to our attention
um but I I think it um a careful reading
would show that this acknowledges that
there circumstances particularly those
in which you would find yourself um
where you have to be able to move
quickly and this would permit that thank
you representative Smith so I did not
see an exemption uh for notification I
what I do read is that the government
entity seeking the information demands
that such notice not be provided and
furnishes the provider with basis of its
authority to make such a de demand so it
would make us we would have to make that
demand and our worry is that if it is um
the 911 operator or making that demand
in a split second notice they may I
guess not make the
demand that this not that we not
notify so I maybe we're confusing it but
or I'm misunderstanding that but but
that's how it reads I guess well to us
if I could just just if I could respond
if it's all right I I thank you for
bringing our attention I think we'll
take some time to to go over it
carefully and one thing that you might
have brought to our attention is the
need to make sure that the 911 people
have appropriate
training in terms of how they react but
whatever I mean we will not ignore your
your suggestion I think I think we think
that
that we're on the case let's put it that
way and we don't have to take any more
time now but so thank you very much for
coming and taking your time to tell us
about
this any other questions from
anyone seeing none thank you thank
you uh Reagan hail am I getting that
right
Ryan a lot of doctors
I can't
read still morning good morning um
chairman Lynn honorable members of the
House Judiciary Committee uh thank you
for the opportunity uh to write
testimony and opposition to House Bill
195 uh relative to the expectation of
privacy and the collection and use of
personal information um for the record
my name is Ryan hail and I'm vice
president government relations for the
New Hampshire Bankers Association new
hampire Bankers Association represents
40 member banks across the state
employing around 6,000 individuals um we
do appreciate the sponsor's interest in
protecting personal information Banks um
are committed to protecting our customer
data and we already have to comply with
strict Federal privacy laws including
Graham leech Bly act which requires
Banks to safeguard customer data with
strict security measures uh the right to
financial Privacy Act uh which requires
us to protect customer financial data
from government access without legal
Authority Fair Credit Reporting Act uh
the bank secrecy act which helps prevent
fraud and identity theft as well as
Federal uh cyber security standards uh
which mandate strong it security and
risk
management along with that banks are
routinely examined for compliance with
these Federal standards and failure to
here could result in fines up to
$100,000 personal liability for
executives and enforcement action by
their regulator um as you heard uh the
legislature just last year um recognized
the importance of protecting consumer
data with the passage of Senate Bill 255
was signed into law last year and I
believe went into effect January 1st of
this year um
Our concern with passage of 195 is this
would disrupt the uniformity that SB 255
set out to uh achieve uh as you may know
Senate Bill 255 was modeled after
similar laws passed in several other
states and uh which is vitally important
um you know lacking any congressional
action on this
front um some of the concerns we have uh
we feel that this could uh could impact
fraud prevention um fraud is on the rise
with with financial fraud is on the rise
with our bank customers um we feel that
it does limit the uh use of biometric
data um that is a key tool in some cases
when uh determining customer is who they
say they are uh we also feel that uh
this may uh uh delay uh fraud
investigations created by creating new
restrictions um and just to sum up the
key risks that we see um there could be
regulatory conflicts and compliance
burdens we could see increased
compliance costs uh there is potential
there is legal and financial liability
with penalties up to $1,000 per
violation operational challenges with
data requests and restrictions and
standard banking um onst standard
banking practice spe specifically
hampering potentially hampering fraud
prevention identity verifications so in
closing um we would like others um urge
the committee to vote inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 195 thank you
for time I'm happy to answer any
questions have any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Christopher Gil gilin
thank you very much Mr chair members of
the committee uh Chris gilrain here
representing TechNet uh we are an
industry Association represented uh
representing about uh 100 companies
throughout the Innovation ecosystem um
here to raise our concerns uh with uh
h195 uh not because we oppose data
privacy legislation in fact we were here
two years ago uh in support of uh s255
which uh is now uh the law of the land
uh as of January um so I I do think it
uh makes sense for us to take a step
back and and recognize uh what you all
did uh last session uh and uh what is uh
the state law as of uh in effect as of
this January uh New Hampshire consumers
have the right to access correct delete
and Export their personal data that is
held by companies that they interact
with they can further opt out of the
sale of that data uh or the processing
of that data for purposes of targeting
uh targeted advertising or digital
profiling the companies that collect
this data uh need to limit what they
collect in the first place and disclose
the uses and the types of parties that
they share that information with they
must maintain that data in a safe and
secure Manner and they cannot process
sensitive data without opt-in consumer
consent this is what is in statute today
uh here in New Hampshire and in nearly
20 other states uh including our uh New
England Neighbors in Connecticut and
Rhode Island uh
h195 uh would be a significant change to
uh the companies that are currently
complying with this law uh the bill uh
for example does not delineate between
controllers and processors or data which
is a Hallmark of every other
comprehensive data Privacy Law this
establishes different responsibilities
for entities that actually interact with
customers versus those that operate in
the background uh as service providers
uh it further does not distinguish
between sensitive data and the kind of
basic units of information that get past
as a matter of course uh in most
internet transactions uh this uh the
main concern here is uh consent fatigue
folks get so many consent requests to
opt in that they simply start clicking
through them the importance of opt-in
consent for sensitive data is that it
gives you pause it you consider whether
sharing this specific information is
necessary or in your best interest when
it comes up with virtually every
interaction you have with a website it
just becomes rote and that's what we
worry about for example so my favorite
uh Campground Moose State uh moose Brook
State Park in gorm um I go to New
Hampshire State parks.gov
uh as is typical with any uh website the
ISP discloses my uh IP address I get my
first popup you consent to this uh then
I click on the Moose Brook link that
takes me to Reser america.com which is
the third party that operates all of the
reservations for all of New Hampshire
state parks uh I get another popup
because I'm going to another site um I'm
going to hit several more roadblocks on
my way to actually processing that
transaction and getting the campsite
that I want now there are comprehensive
data privacy laws uh in Rhode Island and
Connecticut and there are state parks in
Rhode Island and Connecticut not
necessarily as good but you know they
exist um and I could complete that
entire transaction uh seamlessly
I could further tell Reserve
american.com not to sell that
information that I used to process that
uh transaction and if for whatever
reason uh that site wants to ask me
about uh my racial information or needs
my exact geolocation data to for
whatever reason to process that
transaction they have to ask me for that
and that is the opt-in process for the
sensitive data um that's the case in
Rhode Island that's the case in
Connecticut and that is the case in New
Hampshire today as it stands um so uh
with that that's uh we uh ask that the
committee find this uh in expedient to
legislate and allow the relatively new
uh comprehensive data Privacy Law here
in New Hampshire to play
out representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my question so do you
view view this as a
solution looking for a
problem I would say that uh the existing
law s255 which you passed um was the
solution to uh the problems that I
believe uh this is intended to to
address thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Neil
Kirk good good morning Mr chairman and
good morning to committee members for
the record my name is Neil Kirk I live
in wear and I'm representing myself
today I'm here in support of House Bill
195 uh this bill protects an
individual's personal data name dat
birth date social security number
biometric identifiers Etc from
government or business intrusion when
the personal information is given by the
individual to a provider of goods and
services uh excuse me for services and
information such as telephone companies
when you sign up with a telephone
company you give them all sorts of
information they use it but the reason
you're signing up is not to give them
the information but to get the telephone
service same thing with internet service
providers streaming companies social
media providers credit card companies
Etc the reason why this bill is
necessary is that the legal situation is
unclear today as far as the United
States is concerned U Supreme Court
decisions involving the Fourth Amendment
search and seizure proh prohibitions
under those decisions there is no
expectation of privacy and personal
information given to the providers of
these
Services um that means that today a
provider of information and services can
do whatever it wants with the
information the personal information
that you've given
it with or without a subpoena unless a
law dictates otherwise now there is one
federal law for example for banks the
right to privacy act in 2000 which deals
to some extent with this in New
Hampshire the situation is a little
different but there is no statutory
guidance in New Hampshire our Supreme
Court perhaps even under the guidance of
one former Supreme Court Justice um I
don't know if he was there in 2003 or
not but in 2003 in the case of State
versus Goss an expectation of privacy
was created in garbage this is New
Hampshire in
garbage in which was placed in black
plastic bags left within 3 ft of the
street for collection so police couldn't
open the bag and use anything in it
without getting a
warrant in 2005 in the state versus
gubitosi a subpoena to Verizon for
telephone
numbers um called from the cell the
defendant's telephone was valid as the
defendant had no expectation of privacy
in the telephone numbers he called as
distinct from the content of the call
that was a split decision the majority
said nothing in today's decision
prevents the legislature from closely
regulating subpoenas for phone
records and the
concurrence said among other things I
would encourage the legislature to
examine whether telephone billing
records should be protected from the
reach of a process uors
subpoena the New Hampshire Supreme Court
has not yet considered the implications
of the recent um privacy uh
informational Constitutional Amendment
which says an individual's right to live
free from government intrusion in
private or personal information is
natural essential and
inherent now what does this bill do it
clarifies the Constitutional Amendment
with a legislative determination that
the the thirdparty doctrine which allows
access by anyone including the companies
to the information that you've given
them for that service third party
Doctrine says that information is not
subject to privacy
protections that this thirdparty
Doctrine does not operate as an escape
PCH for providers of information and
services to access personal information
for purposes other than providing the
service promised to the individual the
telephone service service or the
streaming service there are exceptions
in this bill if the individual consents
and it has to be real consent not just
you know if you do our service you've
agreed to our terms which we all do but
have no clue what we're agreeing to now
this has to be real consent number two
there's an exception where the provider
of information or Services has the
reason to believe criminal activity is
occurring there's a an exception for
state agencies if the information is
required for them to fulfill the
statutory responsibilities provided the
individual is first notified and has an
opportunity to contest the request
there's an exception for information uh
sought pursuant to a warrant based on
probable cause you got a warrant with
probable cause you can have access to
this information there's an exception
for 911 calls there's an exception for
emergencies danger of death or
significant property damage there's an
exception if it's otherwise required by
Statute somewhere else in the RSA
is and there's an exception for grand
jury testimony or sorry grand jury uh
information subpoenas enforcement in
this case is by the AG only a private
right of action is specifically
excluded I can think of no more
appropriate legislative determination as
to what the Privacy constitutional
privacy Amendment means than House Bill
195 it's right on
point I would add only that um there is
a an amendment that I think improves the
bill one of the things that I think is
the case is that some of these service
providers uh in order to provide the
service the telephone service or the
streaming
service use other people other
organizations to do some of the work for
example they may store information in
the cloud and to the extent they do that
they have to give this personal
information to the cloud provider so I'd
like to see an amendment to the bill
which would go in section um what is it
507 i2i or Roman I if this would be e
this would be an exception the personal
information is disclosed by the third
party provider in order to provide the
service which the individual has
requested so these companies can provide
this information if the purpose of
providing the information is to make
sure I get telephone
service I think that would um eliminate
a lot of some problems that some of
these uh providers have with the bill
and certainly would not in any way um
give access to this personal information
where it would be
inappropriate I hope the committee uh
will look favorably on this bill and I'm
pleased Mr chairman to answer any
questions if there are any
representative
Smith um thank thank you very much good
um good morning um Mr chair lots of
chairs in this room it's important to
recognize that um I do want to begin by
saying we sent out a search party when
we began this bill because we wanted you
to be here for all of it you miss the
presentation of the bill you missed the
comments by a representative of the
insurance industry you missed the
banking uh um industry that indicated by
the way not one but four different I
believe Federal uh laws that uh they
were required to file you missed a very
interesting presentation by the state
police who um who felt that
um their need to move rapidly wasn't
clear enough in the bill um uh
and we we show the sections but they
didn't quite agree that and and and
somebody who represents um uh uh some
technical group I couldn't quite get all
the the code names and but all of those
were opposed to this bill saying that it
did not meet their needs it wasn't
workable it in interfered with their
ability to carry out their
responsibilities and unfortunately Mr
chairman you weren't here to
respond um based on what you and the
other thing is that there has been some
legislation that has passed in the state
since we began this
process um so looking at this bill
you've now mentioned one area that you
think could
help
um improve the bill and we're always
happy
to get that um do
you however see that the language of
this bill makes interferes with the
ability of those institutions that I
refer to um banking Insurance whatever
to carry out their responsibilities in
any way that would be appropriate while
recognizing the rights to
privacy it's a it's a simple question
Rick
thank you representative Smith it's one
of your usual simple
questions um I'm not sure how to answer
it I I apologize for not being here I
was testifying on another bill before
house e DNA and um I kept coming back
and
forward um anytime you have an
informational privacy bill um all those
people who benefit from using that
private information for their own
purposes come out in droves and explain
why the world as they know it um will no
longer
exist to some extent this will impinge
upon their ability to make money or do
their jobs but the question for you as
policy makers is to balance the
interests of privacy for the individual
against the interests of these
organizations both to do their jobs
including making money it's a tough
decision but that's what you're paid the
big bucks for
um when I did come in I heard what I
thought was a speaker a a person who was
testifying talk about a Senate Bill
255 Senate Bill 255 has gotten a lot of
hype but it's basically a useless
bill um in order for you to exercise any
of the rights that you have to uh that
you have under that bill you have to
engage in what amounts to a full-time
effort to contact every company you've
ever done business with
um run through their unique individual
way of exercising your rights because
each of the controllers and that bill
can set up their own systems um it's
about as useless as well excuse me it's
about as useful as um some of the uh
bills that we or some of the procedures
that we now have for exercising our
rights which I mentioned before when you
go online um and you want to use a
particular site they say you have to
agree to all of our terms of services
and we agree because we don't have the
time and frankly some of us including me
don't have the ability to understand
everything they're asking us to
do 255 is not helpful on privacy grounds
it's a great thing for Microsoft and the
others who were pushing it because they
were able to get something through the
states that they couldn't get through
Congress and they can now tell their
people we really care about privacy but
it doesn't work as a practical matter
this bill works as a practical
matter and it's also in the New
Hampshire
tradition if there are
significant problems that some of these
folks have with this
bill I hope the chairman will set up a
subcommittee and try to work some of
them
out if there are legitimate problems
let's resolve them but the basic thrust
of the bill is really
important when I set up a telephone
account when I set up a streaming
account when I use any service and give
my information I find it hard to believe
that it's essential for them to sell
that information for a profit in order
for them to continue to provide me with
the service I know Verizon doesn't need
to do that and I don't know if Verizon
sells us information or
not remember this bill is not only
directed at for-profit companies it's
also directed at state
government which is why the police were
in
here um so
I I haven't answered your question as
specifically I was as I would like to
representative Smith because I wasn't
here and I apologize again to hear the
specifics of the issue but that's one of
the reasons why we have subcommittees to
work on this
bill one follow up
y Mr chair I have to say are you um
aware of the procedures followed um by
the shangan country the the European
economic Community where you have um a
very clear choice to accept all the
conditions accept some of the conditions
or refuse to accept the conditions but
still have access to the site I'm aware
of some of those because I've read about
some of them but it's very complicated
for me and I'm not totally familiar with
them however when I do go on websites
that are in Europe I am always asked
what is it that I wish to do and it's
really
simple reject all accept all and you can
continue using the site
regardless uh that would be a delightful
way if we could deal with privacy issues
in New Hampshire in that simple manner
this bill is an effort to do that by in
effect changing the rules that exist
today which say once you give that
information up it's theirs to use as
they
wish by saying no they have to ask your
permission that's what this bill says if
they want to get that information and
use it they must get your
consent it's not as good as what the
Europeans are doing but it's a step in
that
direction any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Andrew
Kingman just one second yep Mr Kirk do
you have any written testimony that you
could turn
in
appreciate yeah oh all right thank
you I apologize go ahead no sor
and I do not have written comments with
me but we can provide that after if that
would be helpful for the committee um
good morning uh Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Andrew Kingman I
represent the state privacy and security
Coalition uh we're a new england-based
group that represents about 35 companies
and six trade associations uh across um
the country on on uh bills of this
nature um I also have a background as a
privacy compliance attorney helping
clients work through various privacy
laws uh and we're here in respectful
opposition to HB
195 um there have been some questions
about the bill that was passed last year
uh so I just wanted to to start with
what is in that bill to just sort of set
the stage because I think our our
position um is probably you know best
summed up by representative pz's
question which is that last year's Bill
addresses almost every issue that is in
in uh HB
195 uh but does so in a little bit more
thorough way uh with defined terms and
uh much more kind of accepted framework
for how to process personal data uh so
last year's comprehensive bill um the
intent of that was to cover all sectors
of the economy all different types of
companies um you know with the exception
of some that are are covered by federal
like Hippa or Graham leech blly and the
reason for that uh for treating all
companies uh the same and all of the
company's data the same is that we
believe consumers should also have the
same expectations and shouldn't have to
have different uh expectations or
controls based on the type of company
that they're interacting with right so
if I'm a consumer I want to have the
same
expectations um across you know whatever
company I'm interacting with as to how
my data uh is controlled I think uh you
know this has been stated uh before so I
I won't belabor it but uh that generally
sets forth uh some basic
Frameworks one is that you have the
right to opt out of the sale of your
data targeted advertising um and
profiling for certain uh types of
automated decision-making activities but
you were required to provide consent
affirmative consent and optin to any
processing uh which is defined very very
broadly of sensitive data and that
includes terms that are defined in that
law that are not defined in this law
like biometric data uh genetic data
precise geolocation data Etc um these
definitions in Sp
255 is designed to be sustainable over
time so you'll notice that the
definition in that bill of personal data
is uh any data linked or reasonably
linkable to an identified or
identifiable person it doesn't list out
the types of companies covered or the
exact types of data covered because it's
meant to be adaptable over time as
Technologies change um it also I I would
just uh take one note with uh something
that representative Kirk said regarding
having to go through each company to
exercise these rights um the bill
specifically uh provides a mechanism
called the universal opt out mechanism
which requires companies to recognize
certain browser signals uh that a
consumer can put on their browser that
says um opt me out of the sale or
targeted advertising of my information
without having to navigate through a
specific site um I think the other basic
framework of SP 255 that this build
doesn't recognize is this distinction
between controllers and processors as Mr
gilrain flagged but more specifically um
this bill doesn't distinguish between
them in a way that would require
processors which never interact with uh
consumers to be obtaining consent for
them um anytime uh they needed to do
something with that personal data and it
would also require controllers which are
the consumer facing businesses that most
of us uh interact with to obtain consent
to provide for instance your address uh
when you want to purchase something
online um the transmission of that data
to your processor that handles shipping
um would under this bill require consent
but only for certain types of data or
certain types of entities right so again
we believe that um SP 255 addresses the
vast majority of issues that are brought
up here
um does so in a little bit more fleshed
out way that also works with other New
England states that have adopted these
laws um and again this this law has only
been in effect for two months um and so
we think it's worth um sort of letting
that law mature and see if there are
issues with it and if there are we're
we're more than willing to address it
but you know companies spent the last
year working to implement uh the law
that's just been in here for two months
so we think it's worth uh taking a
moment to make sure that that law is
working or to identify issues with it
before we significantly modify it and do
so in a way that doesn't really you know
work with the framework that that's
accepted there so uh would that happy to
take any questions there any
questions seeing none thank you
thanks Rick forio
Judiciary members thank you for allowing
me to speak today for the record I am
Rick Fabo senior director of advocacy
and public affairs for the business and
industry Association New Hampshire's
leading business Advocate I will save
time and not repeat uh testimony this
the valid points that have made been
made already but I want to focus on what
I feel is the most important point to
consider HP 195 is unnecessary with
enactment of the New Hampshire data
Privacy Act that's the 507 um that bill
re uh came to be law in part by the work
of this committee and I will pay you all
the respect as well as the Full House
the full Senate and the governor that we
did not pass a useless bill Senate Bill
255 or the model legislation created by
Senate Bill 255 has now been passed in
20 different states and these laws were
NE necessitate necessitated because of
lack of federal action on data privacy
and the model legislation was critically
important to avoid a costly and
Patchwork of state laws that vary by
state the New Hampshire privacy laws has
been mentioned just went in fact January
1st it is clear on what consent means
what is covered and who is subject to
the law HB 1995 fails on each of those
standards the benefits of model legis
islation should not be erased by
unnecessary laws that confuse both
consumers and businesses please allow
our state data Privacy Law to fully take
effect it is just in the initial phase
for this year where you where the um any
violations can be cured on January 1st
2026 the full effect of law takes place
it it does need time to see uh what
works and possibly what may not work
with all of that we respectively ask you
to vote in expedient to legislate on
House Bill 195 and I'm happy to take any
questions you might have are there any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mara Weston
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee uh my name is Mora Weston
thank you for the opportunity to be here
today I am here on behalf of the New
England connectivity and
Telecommunications Association known as
necta necta is the regional trade
Association that represents private
cable and telecommunications companies
in New Hampshire and several other New
England states are members here include
Bree line Charter Communications and
Comcast together our members service
approximately 485,000 customers and
offer Broadband mobile video and voice
services to more than
695,000
locations in 185 New Hampshire
communities uh I'm here today uh to
respectfully oppose House Bill
195 with that said however neas members
have been committed to protect in the
privacy and security of their customers
personal information and we look to our
participation in Prior sessions on House
Bill 255 uh that resulted in uh New
Hampshire RSA 507 as an example of that
commitment as you've heard uh broadly
507 establishes a privacy framework
creating rights for consumers
enforceable obligations on private
entities that control or process
personal data and sensitive
data and
specifically it creates an optin regime
to protect truly sensitive data and as
that term is
defined it also creates a mechanism for
consumers to opt out of the use of data
for advertising sale and profiling
purposes which terms are also
defined importantly it also creates a
framework for how companies must
communicate
through their privacy policies regarding
how they use data and who they share
data with and for what
purpose this framework as you've heard
is well understood by the regulated
community and compliance is
widespread
uh our primary objection to House Bill
195 is that it proposes changes outside
of the framework of five 7h in a
parallel and really misaligned
way within the context of of the
background and our knowledge of 507 H
I'm going to point out a few specific
flaws that we see in the language as
drafted the terms don't align uh between
House Bill 195 and our current law for
example House Bill 195 would require
isps and cable television providers to
obain optin consent from consumers
before disclosing or making available to
any person a broad range of information
regardless of whether the information
was necessary to provide an underlying
service for example that limits
information sharing between our members
and their business partners from
anything from uh authentication
technology to signing in and out of
services uh to navigate across platforms
for for
example 195 also seeks to protect
individuals as opposed to Consumers this
is important to point out as um it's an
important distinction because a company
for example couldn't disclose under this
law the names and addresses of employees
I.E individuals for purposes of payroll
without first obtaining optin
consent moving on the definition of
personal information is very Broad and
problematic in many respects it does not
distinguish between sensitive data I.E
genetic and biometric data as protected
under 507 and nonsensitive data that's
available from public sources names
addresses phone
numbers one 195 also uses vague terms
like location
information we don't know what that
means is this sensitive location data
data or all location
data moreover uh the phrase available to
the public is used um it is unclear to
us and uh is quite confusing in the
context of looking at 507 H when we also
see a defined term publicly available so
the lack of clarity uh really frustrates
compliance efforts and enforcement and
it is
problematic 195 would upend the careful
balance that we worked very hard to
achieve in 507 H by subjecting all
personal information regardless of
sensitivity to opt-in consent thereby
interfering with business and network
operations this really could impede uh
digital Commerce and degrade internet
experiences to the contrary 507
recognizes every entity that uses data
in one of two
ways the control of data and the
processing of data and you've heard
about that uh again this
morning in
sumary we believe that 195 is
unnecessary it does not provide
additional benefits to Consumers we
agree that 507 H needs time to work
uh I do want to point out before I
conclude that uh law enforcement
requests are already addressed under
current state and federal laws under
federal law the Electronic
Communications Privacy Act regulates how
voice data and video providers May
disclose information to federal state
and local government entities and state
statutes specify in detail the lawful
sharing of information with law
enforcement
entities uh as we've discussed conected
members are required to communicate our
privacy policies and those policies are
legally enforcable
commitments in conclusion we would
recommend that you we would urge you to
recommend HB 1995 inexpedient to
legislate is there are unintended and
undesirable consequences we do not
believe that this clarifies the law in
any way and would not serve the interest
of New Hampshire consumers I thank you
for your attention and appreciate the
opportunity to be here today are there
any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Warren
cormack good afternoon members of the
committee you were on no yep
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Warren Cormac I'm the
Assistant Attorney General in the New
Hampshire Department of Justice who
leads the data privacy unit as within
the consumer protection and antitrust
Bureau uh I would be responsible for
enforcing this
law the Attorney General is not
commenting uh in support or opposition
to this bill uh nor uh commenting on the
rights that it provides opt-in consent
or application to third party
providers my testimony here today is to
raise some issues with the language and
structure of this
bill currently RSA 507 is enforced
through the consumer protection act RSA
358a and the consumer protection act has
certain penalties and enforcement
ability built in it that would apply to
507 for example the consumer protection
act allows the Attorney General to seek
injunctions uh for conduct engaged in by
uh entities that violate the consumer
protection act or
507 there's also subpoena Authority
administrative subpoena Authority
written in
358a that violators of 507 would be
subject
to
and RSA 358a the consumer protection act
has $10,000 penalties per violation up
to $10,000 penalties per violation of
that act this bill uh does not have any
provision for injunctions it doesn't
have any provision for subpoena
Authority
and the penalties that could be issued
under this bill are up to
$1,000 per violation of
it if the legislature is interested in
passing this bill uh the consumer
protection act uh Consumer Protection
Bureau would like to have the ability to
stop harmful conduct through injunctions
and seek meaningful penalties for
violations of data privacy
principles and so there are two possible
ways of going about this uh if this were
tied in with
358a it would be subject to the
exceptions in
358a and so that's one way of going
about it or if this Bill had the added
uh enforcement ability that's present in
358a uh then it would bring it to the
level where it would be able to be
enforced similar to the way that RSA 507
is able to be enforced
thank you thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you that's the last card I have for
House Bill
195 is there anyone else here that
wishes to speak on it that hasn't turned
a card
in seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 195 and open the
hearing on House Bill
522 relative to the expectation of
privacy and personal information
maintained by the state
I recognize representative Lynn to
introduce the
Bill thank thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I I believe this is the
last time I will be up here at least
today uh 52 two is not a bill that we um
enacted or uh that we I don't even think
we considered it to be honest with you
last year but we certainly didn't enact
it um it
um as you can see representative Earth
is the prime sponsor of this bill and um
this bill for lack of a better term is
kind of the flip uh a is intended as a
complement to 195 195 is directed at the
thirdparty providers of information and
services and it
prevents those entities from dis making
disclosures unless the the provisions of
195 um are complied with and as was just
um mentioned that that bill does not
have a private right of action in it
because it so that other words private
individuals would not be able to sue any
of those businesses if there was a
violation 522 is directed to
governmental
entities um and it basically says that I
mean the the key provision the the way
this bill is structured is the key
provision is RSA
507 uh I colon 2 Roman numeral
2 no governmental entity shall acquire
retain or use any personal information
of any individual residing in New
Hampshire from any third party provider
so if you stop right there you say uh oh
how's government going to do its job
because that's the that's the flat
prohibition but then if you go on to
paragraph
three you'll see that there's there's a
there's a huge carve out of exceptions
where which basically says government
can do it job um if there are uh
reasons uh why the government collects
information and let's you know I let's
let's hope I think this is the case
especially in a place like New Hampshire
generally government is not collecting
information for nefarious purposes um
they're generally collecting it for for
appropriate purposes and in SEC
paragraph uh Roman numeral 3 which
begins on line
29 on page one of the bill over
through um line
uh 28 on page two of the bill that um or
I'm sorry not line 28 but line 23 um it
spells out all the uh proper reasons
that government contain can obtain
information and then this um this bill
unlike um 195 this does allow a private
cause of action um and I think the the
rationale there is that um if the
uh
that there are reasons why it may make
sense to allow a private individual to
have a cause of action against the
government where it wouldn't make sense
to allow them to have a cause of action
against uh private businesses um and so
that I mean that basically that's the
the rationale uh for that so with that U
I know um representative representative
Kirk is here um who who also uh has a
strong interest in this bill um I think
it's a good bill I think it does
complement
195 um I'm happy to answer questions and
that and that's about all I have to say
are there any
questions seeing none thank
you you could tell what time it is when
people AR asking questions
uh Neil
Kirk The Honorable Neil Kirk I I
understand thank you Mr chairman I'm
glad to think uh you feel that I'm
honorable but I'm not sure what the
correct procedure is for addressing a
retired
representative um representative Smith
probably knows honorable thank you
honorable yes good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record I'm Neil Kirk I live in we and
I'm here representing myself um 522 is
different from 195 195 covered both the
private sector and the government
sector 522 only applies to the
government sector
so
the various interests that might have
testified against 195 would not be
concerned with 522 because it only
applies to
government um
again like 195 this does not deal with
all privacy interests with respect to
information and government it only deals
again with these third-party providers
of information and services so this is
not a broad sweeping bill that covers
every kind of information that
government might seek it only applies to
the information that we provide to third
provide third party providers of
services and information and it
basically says when the state wants
information from them it can't get it
unless as representative Lynn said it
falls under one of these exceptions and
the exceptions are very broad uh
representative F and I dealt several
years ago with a variety of state
agencies to try to get the language that
would allow them to continue to do their
jobs and still protect privacy and that
I think is reflected on page two
line
one this is an
exception personal information acquired
collected retained or used by any state
regulatory or administrative
agency when such acquisition collection
retention or use is within the agency's
regulatory investigative adjudicatory or
administrative
function um and so the insurance
department for example can continue to
use or gain access to these various
sources of information when it is
fulfilling its statutory
functions
um
the one issue which is addressed in 195
which is not really addressed here is to
is it has to do with the state police or
any police um the way this is set up the
cops would have to get a a search
warrant in order to get information from
any of these sources uh that poses a
real problem for them in 195 it was said
they didn't get and need to get a search
warrant they could still use a um
subpoena which as you know is an
administrative kind of device but it
required them to give notice to the
person about whom they were collecting
information and give that person an
opportunity to contest The subpoena that
is obviously a problem for for the
police and how that's worked out I don't
know but that provision is not in this
bill and you might want to include that
provision from 195 in
um there's a penalty here individuals
have a right to
sue um there's a prevention there's a
clause here which says if the federal
law preempts this the federal law
prevails um
this bill is not as broad as 195 and
from my point of view it's it it it's
not as desirable but I understand the
opposition to 195 and if this committee
decides to hold on to 195 to work on it
or to do something else with the bill um
I would still recommend that you look to
522 modify it as you need to because
this does implement the Privacy
Amendment and says and places limits on
what state government can do to access
our information uh representative Earth
asked me um what do this does this
prevent the state from collecting
databases or creating databases on
individual the answer is
no um the state can create a database on
individuals but the only information
that could go into that database would
be publicly in publicly available
information so if I went on Facebook and
posted a whole bunch of pictures and let
the world see those there's nothing in
this bill that would prevent this would
prevent the state and I don't know that
they're doing it now from starting a uh
database on Neil Kirk and putting all of
those pictures from Facebook in that
database but what they couldn't do in
that database is including any
information from telephone companies
internet providers service providers and
so forth into that database that would
be prohibited under this bill but not a
database itself why representative Earth
was concerned about databases I don't
know as far as I know the state does not
have databases on individuals except in
connection with investigatory activities
that are the legitimate function of
agencies to Summit up whatever you do
with 195 522 should go forward modify it
as you need to do to account for
particular state agency issues thank you
Mr chairman if there are questions I'd
be prepared to answer even if it goes
into lunchtime are there any
questions representative Smith might
have one I'm I'm sorry but I I'm a
little confused because you said just
said something about um
195 uh with reference to the state
police and I was pleased to see that the
representatives of the State Police is
still here because I believe that the
sponsor and others
uh say that there is a very clear
exception in uh
195 in situation and I know we're
talking about 522 now but you're you've
just combined them so it's very
important to note that there is an
exception when an emergency situation
exists and you can't go through the um
who struck John issue you've got to just
move very quickly and I believe that
what you just said seemed to contradict
that
um there is an exception and it does
apply to State Police it's D on page two
line 8 for an emergency so the police
could clearly get this in the case of
emergency but where it's not an
emergency where the police are
investigating something then um the
provisions of 522 would require them to
give would not allow them to get
subpoena whereas they can get a subpoena
in 195 so you might want to consider
taking the subpoena language from 195
and putting it into 522 so the police
can use a subpoena in appropriate
investigatory
cases well thank you very much we're
more concerned with the other we're
concerned with situations in which there
just isn't time the that clearly is
covered by 522k not just for the police
but for any state agency thank you are
there any other questions seeing none
thank you thank you Mr
chairman Deana Dennis
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Dena Dennis and I serve as director
of regulatory and legislative affairs
with the community power Coalition of
New Hampshire the community power
Coalition is a joint Powers agency
established pursuant to rsa's 53-a and
53- e we procure and Supply electricity
and related services to member Community
power aggregations on a default
basis pursuant to rsa's 53e and also RSA
374 df2 Roman
1-A our members include 66
municipalities and four counties serving
approximately 200,000 customers across
the state since launching Community
power service in the spring of 2023
we've helped customer re customers
realize more than $22 million in savings
on their electricity
bills we are respectfully um opposed to
House Bill 22 and our concern is
actually quite narrow um and pertains to
section one only um and specifically uh
proposed RSA
507-i 2 um Roman 3 subsection e on page
two starting on line 12 um and that's
related to the condition that personal
information be quote requested of and
supplied by a third-party provider of
information and services for named
individuals Only We believe that that
current language um would prevent the
continued operation of community power
programs in New Hampshire including
those served by the community power
Coalition the community power Coalition
and other community power aggregations
are already subject uh and must comply
with various state laws and rules
related to data access and sharing um
including RSA 363 colon 37 and 363 colon
38 which specifies what we as a service
provider can and cannot do with respect
to individual customer
data I've included in my testimony um
citations and relevant portions of these
and other statutes and the rules um in
my written testimony for your reference
and information um we believe that
existing law provides uh that in order
to launch new community power programs
and enroll new customers into existing
Community power programs the community
power Coalition and other community
aggregations rely on electric utilities
as third parties to provide us with this
data for all individuals which includes
personal information as defined in
section one of the bill this data is
needed since we are required um by the
community power aggregation act or RSA
53- col 7 to mail written notification
to each retail Electric customer within
the municipality or County service area
where the community power program is
provided if we do not have the ability
to receive this data from the utilities
there is no way for us to know specific
named individuals which is the approach
proposed via subsection e um all that
being said we think that there's a
relatively simple solution to address
our concern and that is to remove the
provided that condition um of SE
subsection e which is on page two lines
12- 16 um and as shown on page four of
my written testimony um so sub what
we're proposing is that subsection e
would simply read as the follows as the
follow cases where the acquisition
collection ret attention or use of
personal information is authorized or
required by state or federal law period
and the remainder of lines 13 through 16
would be
removed um so with that thank you for
your time and consideration of my
testimony I welcome any questions are
there any
questions seeing none thank
you Warren McCormack
good afternoon my name is Warren Cormac
I'm the Assistant Attorney General uh in
charge of data privacy enforcement in
the New Hampshire Department of Justice
consumer protection and antitrust
Bureau the Attorney General doesn't take
a position on this bill I testify to
raise an issue with a language that
might result in unintended
consequences the Department of Justice
is a law enforcement agency and this
bill applies to Regulatory and
administrative agencies but not law
enforcement
agencies however uh the consumer
protection and antitrust Bureau
regularly receives substantial amounts
of data uh
from providers from entities uh after
issuance of an administrative subpoena
pursuant to their civil law enforcement
Authority and these subpoenas are
regularly issued against financial
institutions covered by this
bill and it's a core part of the
investigations of a lot of what the
consumer protection and antitrust Bureau
does like for example investigating
violations of the consumer protection
act with respect to uh home contractors
oftentimes an administrative subpoena
would be issued to a bank uh to look
into the books of that type of a
situation so because this bill could
inhibit the ability of the consumer
protection and antitrust Bureau to
engage in consumer protection
investigations the suggestion is that
law enforcement agencies be added to the
list of regulatory and administrative
agencies covered by this
Bill thank you any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you that's the last card I have on House
Bill
522 is there anyone else here that wants
to speak on House Bill
522 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 522
and it looks like we have about a half
an hour before our next hearing so I'm
going to recess the house Judiciary
Committee until one
o'
how
e
e e
order and uh we'll open the hearing on u
h
hcr1 and I will recognize uh the prime
sponsor representative uh Greg
Hill thank you Mr chairman um good
afternoon everyone colleagues uh for the
record I am representative Greg Hill a
chair legislative Administration and I'm
here to introduce house uh hdr1 for
short
um I uh will be here to explain why I
filed the red resolution and what it
does I should begin by saying this is
not the first time this exact reg
resolution was filed in 2003 the resolu
ution passed the house 213 to 142 and
died in the Senate I read the entire
file including the testimony submitted I
believe the reason some members of the
Senate chose to let it die was a feeling
that they didn't want to embarrass the
court from the testimony I read it seems
clear though that most of the
justices um or most of the testimony uh
felt that the Claremont ision had laid a
proverbial
egg in cander I should also
explain that much of my testimony here
today was stolen from that 2003
historical record for I too believe the
Claremont decision was wrongly
decided with that as a backdrop let me
say the purpose of this resolution is to
make it clear that we the House and
Senate find the lines of responsibility
between the judicial and legislative
branches to have been crossed in the
1993 Claremont foundational
decision all subsequent Claremont
decisions but most especially the
current conil decision lawsuit have
doubled down on that original Crossing
of lines of separation between
branches hcr1 is needed now as a measure
of our resolve to defend our sworn
constitutional responsibilities now and
in the future
our system of government is based on the
system of check our our form of
government is based on the system of
checks and balances one of these checks
and balances is the separation of powers
among the three branches hcr1 does not
reject the theory of judicial review it
does not assert that the legislature or
the governor can
overrule Court decisions or even that
courts cannot review legislation
affecting educ or tax
policy rather hcr1 simply affirms the
well settled proposition that the power
of judicial review is not the power to
direct the other branches to pass
legislation and that consequently by the
directives of the Supreme Court in the
Claremont decisions that the legislature
is required to pass certain legislation
based on parameters set forth by the
court in other words these are not
binding upon the
legislature as we took office we all
swore an oath to protect our
constitution I'll assume you have read
and have an understanding of both parts
of our constitution part first is the
Bill of Rights part second is the form
of government one of the many flaws of
the Claremont decision was the justices
finding the word cherish in article 83
of part two the form of government
section and succeeding in all sort of
mental gymnastics to turn that into a
right a right suitable for the first
part of the
Constitution if you believe in the
Constitution and I think we all do then
you know precise words and placement
matter those at the Constitutional
Convention in the n in the 1850s
understood that well and tried
unsuccessfully to put the words of
article 83 dealing with school funding
into part one by resolution
that resolution
failed words matter and placement
matters our framers changed a word from
the Massachusetts
Constitution that we used as a template
when creating our New Hampshire
Constitution I've given you copies of
both to highlight the significant change
that was made the word legislature was
changed to
legislator in our ratified constit
stion the framers it seems wanted the
individual legislators to cherish
education not the entire
legislature words have meaning and I
believe the justice and the trial court
who first heard the claron testimony
understood that I've given you an
excerpt typo except um it should be
excerpt of his decision that was
overturned by the Supreme Court it's
page
three and it
says New Hampshire's encouragement of
literature Clause contains no language
regarding Equity uniformity or even
adequacy of
Education thus the New Hampshire
Constitution imposes no qualitative
standard of Education which must be met
likewise the New Hampshire Constitution
imposes no quantifiable Financial Duty
regarding education there is no mention
of funding or even of providing or
maintaining education the only duty set
forth is the amorphous duty to cherish
public schools and to encourage private
and public
institutions the language of part two
article 83 is hitory not mandatory
this decision is not often me mentioned
by those who feel the Claremont
decisions represent gospel neither are
the words of Justice Horton who
dissented in Claremont 2 but I have
given you an excerpt of that dissent as
well he said my problem is that I was
not appointed to establish education po
policy nor to determine the proper way
to finance the implementation of this
policy those duties in my opinion reside
with the representatives of the people
my job is to determine whether the
structures for providing and financing
education meet the mandates of the
Constitution the original drafters of
hcr1 14 from 2003 proclaimed and I agree
that what the drafters of the Claremont
decisions did was to claim innocence in
words but crossed the Constitutional
lines in action the legislature and not
the courts were given the exclusive
right to make laws and spend money I've
given you a copy of part two Article 5
in this package that clearly says just
that and so while the courts say it is
up to the legislature to
define adequacy a word The Claremont
Court made up by the
way and devise a scheme to provide State
funding by right by dismissing every
single attempt by the legisl to do that
they have effectively broken the intent
of the Constitution that allows the
legislature to make laws and spend money
exclusively this HCR makes clear that I
wish the legis what I wish the
legislature had done in
1993 say clearly and loudly thank you
justices for your hard work and opinion
on this matter but our reading of the
Constitution counts as well and we'll
act as we see bit after all we are
elected by and represent the people of
New
Hampshire with that I'll end my
testimony um and ask for you to do
nothing other than your sworn Duty
regarding our Constitution and protect
the separation of
powers I understand there's a number of
people speaking and I would limit um any
questions to one or two uh Mr chairman
thank you very much questions for this
witness representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my
question has this come up before last
year when it came up the issue
about um the issue about the
Claremont um The Claremont decision I
mean it's been since
1993 so it's been quite a while has it
come up in the past that this is to our
legislated government I think it's fair
to say there's uh quite a few people
here that thank you for your question
that are um clared out um I think uh
there's been a significant number of of
pieces of legislation U that have come
before this committee as well as others
um not to mention um you know I think
we're maybe up to Claremont eight or
nine within the uh within the Judiciary
itself followup
yes does this have anything to do with
the fact that we have the um education
funding court case right now that's
pending um in the courts or in our oh in
the courts um it does only in the
standpoint of what I said in my
testimony that um each time a
new um set of of uh plaintiffs come
before the court it seems um the
Judiciary has gone even one step further
in as I said doubling down on uh this
separation of powers
um what I'm trying to avoid here um or
and part part of the reason for filing
this resolution is I don't see an end to
these um it seems that every time a a
case comes before the court um the
legislature tries to do something to um
appease that decision and it lasts for a
year or two and then another court case
comes I don't see anything in this
existing one this conval case um that's
going to be the the end all case um I
think we are facing a NeverEnding supply
of um of um plaintiffs um and and
defendants um and that's what I'm trying
to avoid this endless supply of of cases
thank you thank you other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much representative thank you uh next
I'm going to call on representative Pam
Brown
please good afternoon committee members
and Mr chairman
for the record I'm representative Pam
Brown from the towns of Kingston and
East Kingston and I also clerk on the
house education funding committee I'm an
economist and a college professor I here
to express my very strong support for
hcr1 on our two education committees
policy and funding we've been actively
working to to address and more clearly
Define two Central issues the
appropriate scope of subjects to be
covered in New Hampshire schools and the
appropriate level and method of funding
Education Services in New Hampshire we
are well aware of the continued
deliberations regarding these issues in
our
courts I'm left wondering why the
judicial branch has become activist
concerning these matters and how they
have reached what appear to be arbitrary
political decisions regarding article 83
for
example I've scoured several
dictionaries and the aorai none of them
indicates a close synonym for cherish is
to fund or
Finance in 1784 when article 83 was
established I believe the average school
had at most six or seven
grades what is the exact scope of
Education levels to be financed the
court seems to assume K to 12 but but
why not grades uh 1 through
8 when basic reading and computational
skills are nailed down or K through
Community College or K through grad
school finally estimates of adequate
Education costs are tied to debatable
metrics measuring
success in the New Hampshire 2020
commission report it indicates that
increased School attendance is an
evidence-based measure of
success attendance is an input not an
output such as assessment
results so in short New Hampshire's
education cake is isn't Half Baked at
this point all of the ingredients
haven't been
assembled these are legislative matters
and not judicial I'll continue to watch
the Court's decisions and activities but
we're also going to be doing our work
thank you questions for this witness
representative Perez sorry thank you
thank you for taking my question um
perception okay I have a concern and
trust me I'm a big constitutional person
but I have a concern about if they say
we should do something and we don't do
that what is the perception to our
constituents do you see any issue if uh
the courts come back and say we need to
increase funding for example to all the
schools all the public schools and we
say well we don't have to do that do you
see an issue with what the perception on
that would be
I think the biggest problem is that the
districts want local control of what
they provide to their students and they
may want to limit it to basic subject
matter other school districts may want
to have a swimming pool or tennis courts
so when we look at the average cost of a
student across districts we have to
really drill down and look at what each
district is doing for their students and
some districts want to spend a lot with
many bells and whistles and others
prefer just to have the basic skills and
Athletics and limit it to that so to me
they really need to um allow the local
districts to decide what particular
Services they'd like to include in their
budgets and by mandating an average cost
of Education they're really overlooking
all of these details and I to me that's
just a local
issue other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you so much next I'm going to call on
David Trumble of where New Hampshire
Rumble thank you Mr chairman and
committee members my name is David
Trumble I'm from the town of whereare I
oppose this bill for a few reasons first
the resolution I think leaves out half
of the New Hampshire Constitution's
article on separation of powers at the
beginning of the resolution in the
whereas section they mentioned the
separate and independent branches of
government but that's only half of the
sentence in article 37 the second half
of the sentence goes on to describe the
three branches as having quote a chain
of connection that binds the whole
fabric of the Constitution into one
dissoluble Bond of Union and Amity
they're not completely separate branches
of government they're supposed to work
together second so what is the duty of
the judicial branch it's the duty of the
New Hampshire Supreme Court in the words
of G allanar and he is the director of
the center for State constitutional
studies at ruter and a professor of
political science there and he wrote an
article called thinking about separation
of powers in New Hampshire the duty of
the New Hampshire Supreme Court is to
say what the law is Additionally the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has the duty to
enforce the Constitution as was
explained by judge Levi Woodbury and all
of us know that he was not only on our
state supreme court he was a governor
Speaker of the House a senator Justice
on the US Supreme Court and a secretary
of US navian Treasury he said that the
rule of law was only one benefit that
would flow from judicial Independence
independent courts and only independent
ones could also help to enforce the
Constitution so the courts have two jobs
tell us what the law is to enforce the
Constitution so the question is did the
Supreme Court overstep its bounds in the
Claremont case and I would say no the
court in Claremont laid out the
framework for the legislature one it's
the state's duty to fund an adequate
education for all children in the public
schools and two to Define inadequate
education the court did this because of
prolonged inaction on the part of the
state which failed to live up to its
constitutional obligations the court
gave considerable difference to the
legislature and the governor quote in
claremount one to fulfill their
responsibilities to defining the
specifics of and the appropriate means
to provide through public education and
in Claremont 2 they noted the
legislature would quote have lied wide
latitude in choosing the means by which
public education is be to be supported
if the court had not pointed out the
prolonged legislative inaction it would
not have been doing its job which is to
say what the laws and to help enforce
the constitution in those two cases they
didn't just come up with something
willy-nilly they went back to the 1700s
in Claremont 1 they quoted they cited
governor wenworth who made it clear in
his address to the council chamber of
the house of assembly in
1771 that the duty to educate remained
with the state they cited the house in
the state in 1795 which said the same
thing and they say this statement has
significant probative value as an
indication that the Contemporary
understanding of article 83 imposed a
duty on the state to provide Universal
education and support the schools they
didn't make it up they went back it's
spend the law of New Hampshire for 250
years that brings us lastly to third
what's the do of the legislature in this
situation if you choose to ignore Court
decisions I believe that you not only
would lead to less funding for education
but you would weaken yourself as a body
this is from an article in the American
Journal of legal history in 1995 another
article on separation of powers in New
Hampshire uh Thomas Lowry were the
legislature to ignore the Court's honest
constitutional objections legislators
would severely undermine their own
authority their laws would be exposed is
mere acts of force deserving no respect
the resolution focuses on the idea of
independent branches of government
ignoring that they are tied together if
you weaken this you weaken all of the
branches and I leave you with one other
thought if you can ignore the courts
then what's to stop the Executive Branch
from ignoring you when you make a law it
gets implemented by the executive branch
they pass regulations the regulations
the common understanding is they must ad
here to the law the regulations can only
fill in the details they can't add to or
subtract from the law it has to be
approved by the legislature if you're
capable of ignoring the court what's to
stop the Executive Branch from ignoring
you and just doing essentially whatever
they want and then you would have three
weak branches of government we're better
off with three strong branches of
government that work together in this
case you've got a clear directive that
goes back 250 years we should implement
this longstanding duty of our and lastly
you have an alternative remedy if you
don't like the court
decision argue for a constitutional
amendment to make it very clear if
enough people would support it then that
would solve the problem but ignoring the
court is not the correct step thank you
questions for this witness yeah
representative
Smith thank you um what do you think
would have happened if low these many
years ago um the then incumbent Governor
had agreed to accept the augen Blick
formula and so that would have can you
just spell that out a little bit more
I'm sorry well that's all right I'll
pass thank you all right other questions
for this yes representative
trp are you in favor of local control of
the schools
yes um are you familiar with the the
phrase who pays the pipe for cause the
tune yes do you think that uh the state
should they decide to uh uh fully fund
the schools would be within their
purview to uh Take Over Control of local
schools no why the the court in
Claremont said that the it pointed out
the historical reason that the local
school dri districts were created to
help the state administer its Duty so
local control people have local control
the duty the duty to fund it lies with
the state the control lies with the
local
towns representative Horan um I guess
that's the flip side of this question
which was do you feel that a school
board which has more money at its
disposal from whatever Source has more
control and more over what options it
chooses to educate the uh students in
his district as opposed to one that
doesn't have enough funding absolutely
and if there's these two cases you've
got conal and the Rand case the convel
case is the base adequacy the Rand case
would be differentiated a so special in
that if if the state were to live up to
its duty to do base adequacy as
prescribed by conel plus lived up to
special ed or at least say 60% of it
assuming the feds ever did their 40%
that would be a base from which any town
in the State even towns like Newport
would be able to have adequately
functioning schools because they could
add on what they could afford from their
local property taxes and if the towns
that are well more well off they can do
whatever they want to as well but I
think the state is the Constitution
makes it clear every town should be
receiving from the state base adequacy
plus special ed that would be enough to
allow every town to have a chance so
that every child in the state gets a
good
education other questions yes
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking me correct me if I'm wrong
but is it it's my understanding that the
court that the case that is before the
courts right now is to
increase that
base of adequacy Education increase That
Base so by doing this are we saying to
them if you say we need to increase this
and we as legislators say we don't have
to do that
do you feel that that's okay to do for
us thank you for the question
representative prz so two things the
court is not saying that we should
increase the the court was the the the
the conil trial happened it went to the
Supreme Court Supreme Court said not
enough here they remanded it back to the
superior court for further Evidence they
held a 3-we trial they brought in dozens
of witnesses superintendent and finance
people and said this is the bare minimum
that we could do at a base adequacy not
not looking at special ed but just base
adequacy so they're not really saying
let's increase base adequacy they're
saying what is base adequacy and the
Supreme Court instructed that trial
court judge to determine how much does
it cost to to meet base adequacy so
that's what that judge did he was
instructed to do that he did what he was
instructed to and that happens in cases
all the time Supreme Court remands back
to the supremor court give us more facts
you don't have enough facts for us to
make a final decision so if that happen
I think the people of the state would
say okay that's the way we're going to
do it it's the state's job to fund good
then the state will come up with some
funding source and then as I answered to
representative Horan then the towns
would be able to on top of that add on
whatever they
wanted sure other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir next I'm going to call on H Caitlyn
berer
no hi
hi good afternoon honorable chairman and
members of the Judiciary Committee my
name is Caitlyn Bernier and I live in
marac I'm here today as a taxpayer a
parent and a member of our school budget
committee I this is this was my first
year on the budget committee and I went
all in I spoke with everybody I could I
read all the things I compared to all
the different
towns I I went in deep um and it was
enlightening and also concerning um so
fast forward to last night we had our
deliberative session for our school uh
District budget and the past few years
it's gone from like 20 people going to
like 400 people coming so we had at
least 400 people there last night it was
a a big deal for us um and uh we heard
from many taxpayers about how they can't
afford another property tax increase but
they are seeing the progress from our
students in Reading because we have
invested uh taxpayer dollars into to
prioritizing it ourselves within our
district um The Narrative of pinning
neighbors against neighbors for one that
is rightfully demanding an appropriate
adequate education for their young
children and the equally valid um are
our seniors and those on a fixed income
with genuine concerns about affording
the houses they raised their children in
this has been a familiar theme in recent
years of my Hometown and many towns in
New Hampshire last night was different
than I had anticipated in some ways and
it gave me hope you see throughout the
budget season many of us have been able
to educate more of our constituents on
the actual cost of providing an adequate
education in
2025 we have informed them about the
conval and Rand law lawsuits and how
unfortunately little our state has been
contributing to the future generation s
of New Hampshire they have seen the
decrease in funding over the last 10
years they know that the that currently
they're trying to overturn a ruling that
requires the state to provide proper
funding for our children's education
they know you're willing to spend money
on the select few who use efas but not
the majority who use public school they
know that the tax burden falls on them
when those they elected continue to fail
them so this time for every one person
who spoke about how they can't take the
tax increase I watched an average
citizen who maybe has never spoken at
one of these before go to the microphone
and say that we need to hold the state
accountable for properly for how we have
not been properly funding an adequate
education and to speak to their
representatives and each time the room
broke out in Applause I'm here today on
behalf of my community and our future
Generations that deserve better than
your excuses be accountable and listen
to your people when we say we agree with
the Claremont and conal cases and
expectations of the state to and to
uphold those
expectations the cost of uh educating a
student has increased and when I
graduated from the high school that now
I get to find out the budget on 20 more
year 20 years ago um our state actually
provided more funding for our town 25
years ago than they do
now we have inflation we have all these
things that we say are the reasons
everything goes up what's the reason
yours is going down and why are we just
finding excuses and ways to say maybe if
we you know pick this one verbage
instead of just going all students
deserve to be properly educated and have
an adequate education and it shouldn't
be at the cost of the parents so that is
all I have today oh I'm in opposition I
didn't I meant to lead with that I'm in
opposition of this and um that is all I
have and I am open to questions thank
you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
next I'm going to call on Gregory Sor
please thank you Mr chairman pleasure to
be back here it's been a long
time I'm a my name is Gregory sorg I'm a
former four-term representative in the
New Hampshire house all on this
committee and uh the last one uh as Vice
chair I've been an attorney in the state
since 1981 I'm a real estate
practitioner I work out of my house in
Easton and yet I'm in the strange
position of uh relevant to what we're
talking about here as being the
attorney representing 27 house members
and two senators as a mikas cier in the
conval litigation that's now going
on we were able to
get ourselves involved in that case
through the
uh the language of article 80 of article
83 of part two
which which uh puts the duty that's
under under consideration here on the
legislators not on the legislature as
the parallel provision of the
Massachusetts con constitution does that
means that what's under contention here
is the content of the duty of each of
you and all of your colleagues and it's
being hashed about in the Supreme Court
in the conval case by the judicial
branch and the executive
branch they're going to tell you how
much what the the uh limitations on your
Authority
is back in uh late
2018 no
2019 uh representative Hill and former
pres of balbon and I went to the
Attorney General's office to urge them
the the conell case was then before the
court and to urge them to argue that
that uh the uh Claremont precedent
should be
overruled because with each iteration of
the Claremont
case in subsequent appeals the court has
involved itself more and more into
policy areas that it's supposed to stay
out of what it's tried to do is to
instruct the legislature as to what they
what kind of laws they should pass
they're not they won't order what sort
of laws you must pass they're they're
not the precise laws you should pass but
what to guide you towards what they want
you to do because they know they can't
tell you what laws to pass so if you
pass the laws that they like they can
say well we didn't do it we didn't make
a policy decision the legislature did
but the more they involved themselves
in putting blinders on the and narrowing
the focus of the legislature the more
they're in fact making policy decisions
even though they're not saying
so on behalf of of the legislative as I
as I called them we filed several
pleadings we filed a brief in the 2020
appeal which basically explained why
Claremont was incorrectly decided in
when it came back on another appeal in
2024 we filed a memorandum which
basically was to remind the court of the
uh uh brief and explain why and how the
the court should overrule Claremont and
both efforts were objected to by the uh
plaintiffs which is to me rather absurd
way of proceeding because they they are
saying in effect that the legislature
even through these uh 31 of them I
represented should not have any voice in
what's going on while your future is
being your future ability to legislate
is being contended over by the
Legislative by the executive and the
judicial branches
the uh the plaintiffs actually filed a
motion to strike our memorandum to which
we filed an objection and I go over this
history because I've prepared for the
committee a compilation of those four
pleadings are our brief from 2020 our
memorandum from September of last year
the objection that was filed to it or
the motion to strike it which was filed
by the plaintiffs and our objection to
that motion to
strike uh are are in here and I'll
submit them to you
the current situation in the conval
litigation is that the latest appeal has
been briefed and argued it was argued
last December 11th I believe and uh
we're awaiting a ruling the plaintiffs
have asked the Supreme Court to enforce
the the order of the Superior Court
which so basically orders the
legislature to spend another half
billion dollars in in education funding
to fund adequacy as it was determined by
uh judge ruoff in the Superior Court
this is the culmination of 30 years of
sparring between the legislature and the
court on this issue this eventuality was
totally predictable back in 1994 I
remember when I first read The Claremont
decision I could see where it was going
to head you could not comply with the
Claremont decision in full that is 100%
funded adequate Education Without a
broad-based
tax and we know how much we talk about
cherish how much we cherish not having a
broad-based tax in the state an income
tax or sales
tax and what the court did was place the
legislature be between the proverbial
Rock and the hard place you either
comply with the court and anger your
constituents who put you into office to
preserve New Hampshire as a as a
uh a state without a broad-based tax or
you do what your constituents want and
repudiate the
court so now we have now that we've come
to the point where the court is on the
verge if they if they do uh affirm judge
Rua's order we're in the position where
we have three Alternatives
here the judicial branch either backs
off by overruling Claremont or that
failing legislative branch either
surrenders to the court thereby
betraying the wishes of of your
constituents and throwing the state into
fiscal
chaos or you repudiate The Claremont
decision via hcr1
and thereby recover your constitutional
Authority as the exclusive State policy
Maker Now the opponents of hcr1 claim
that passing hcr1 and repudiating the
court would create a constitutional
crisis well I contend that we've been in
a constitutional crisis since 1993 when
Claremont The Claremont Court knowing
and deliberately cross the Rubicon by in
interjecting itself into education
policy and funding matters
now I want I want to present a
hypothetical
here to illustrate what I'm urging you
to consider suppose suppose that a
murder had been committed the murderer
apprehended no problem knowing that he
was
guilty and the trial is pending in the
Superior Court you had a very
sympathetic
victim and the accused was very
OD and they they got the evidence
against them but perhaps it was the the
search that got that recovered the
evidence is kind of dicey and it's
possible that the case might be thrown
out on a technicality so in order to
prevent that the
legislature uh passes a
bill and it does it with all the you
know all the forms of legislation
whereas Clauses be it enacted by the
Senate and the House of Representatives
and what the bill says it declares the
defendant guilty and imposes a life
sentence on him and the governor signs
that in the law and it's it's duly
enrolled given a chapter number and then
delivered to the judge what would the
judge do with that the judge would
repudiate he would just throw it
away why would he do that it's because
it would it would be a Judicial act that
was made to look like a legislative act
it crossed the line of the separation of
powers so my question to you is
shouldn't this work both
ways Claremont The Claremont decision
was a legislative act all gussied up to
look like a judicial act it was very
thinly disguised as such in my brief I
explained why the court got it wrong
because they read something into the
Constitution that isn't there they read
something out of the Constitution that
was there and they fabricated the
historical data that led them to that
decision and they did that all in seven
pages that's quite a ther for such a
short
decision so to conclude I would say I
would suggest you that legislators are
required to sign to to swear to the same
constitutional oath as do judges the
judges violated theirs in 1993 and
continue to As Long As Claremont endur
as precedent the justices perverted
their interpretive function to transform
a policy issue into a constitutional
issue they use judicial forms to perform
and provide cover for legislative
acts I urge members of this committee
and of the house not to violate Euro
don't allow the Court's intrusion into
your constitutional authority to
continue I Ur you to vote ought to pass
on hcr1 and start the process of
reigning in the Judiciary saving it from
the consequences of its own Folly and
conceit and restoring the legislative
Branch's exclusive authority to set
State policy I thank the committee for
hearing me out thank you questions for
this witness yes yes representative
Burch thank you Mr chair
as long as we're talking about
Oaths and as members of the legislature
you know we take an oath to uphold the
Constitution of the United States in the
state of New Hampshire as attorneys we
take a similar oath we're considered
officers of the court so I want to ask
you with that OB with those obligations
in mind when discussing a bill that
essentially says that if the legislature
decides they don't like what a court
orders they have a right to ignore it so
I want to give you a different
hypothetical and ask you're a practicing
lawyer you've got a bunch of clients who
are let's say divorce
clients and they've been subject to a
number of court
orders I'm wondering how you decide as
an attorney which court orders you tell
your clients not to pay attention to
because they're somehow outside the
Court's Authority and which clients you
tell that's a court order it's your job
to obey it unless it's overturned
through legal process well I'm just one
person I'm one attorney I'm talking
about an issue between two coordinate
branches of the government here but I'm
asking you because you're testifying and
making statements in support of this
bill I'm asking
you how you would carry out in your own
life this concept of uh judicial
nullification oh in my life I I would
have the client obey the court order no
question about it it's not for me to
decide what which orders to obey or not
thank you but that's that's different
this is an Institutional issue
here I
questions for this W yes representative
Manos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I apologize I
didn't catch your name Gregory sword
sword org attorney sword um I wanted to
ask you you spoke about
repudiation um but this this bill that's
before us is a house concurrent
resolution so is it not correct that it
is would even if passed would simply be
a sense of the house and this is not
would not be binding on any way
on um an appropriation from the
legislature or a non-appropriation from
the legislature this this would not have
the effect of a bill is that correct not
as I see it it would be a the
legislature stating its sense that
Claremont was not a legitimate exercise
of the judicial function and therefore
is not binding on the legislature and
the legislature thereby reasserts its
own exclusive authority over the entire
subject of the Claremont which is
funding and of education and education
policy yes follow up in your
professional view what would be the
consequence of um not following a house
concurrent resolution of of a violation
of a house concurrent resolution what
would be the consequence of that
violation by the house itself well by
the C if if the court did not comply
with the house resolution or did not as
you you talked about
repudiation what would be the
consequence well we go back to Alexander
Hamilton when he characterized the
Judiciary as the weakest branch of
government because it depends upon the
legislative branch for its for its
functioning they have to pay for its
facilities and everything and they
depend upon the executive branch for
enforcing its orders all the all the
judicial branch has going for it is
Judgment so if the if the legislative
branch through a solemn act like passing
this this house concurrent resolution uh
determines that this was not a
legitimate exercise of the judicial
function there's nothing the court can
do about
it you you hold the whip hand
here I was constantly frustrated when I
was here at the house that that the
house and the Senate don't understand
the extent of their Authority
uh I was dismayed by the the amount of
uh Authority that would be conceded to
the Judiciary and would be delegated to
the uh Executive Administrative agencies
the the the legislature seems content to
let other people us make an enforce
policy other question of yes
representative
pno thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question earlier we heard
testimony that should the legislature
resist the court the decisions of the
court that that would weaken the
legislature but it seems to me if I'm
not mistaken that what you are saying is
that resisting a court decision would
strengthen the
legislature I I've always felt that it
would be a healthy thing if in an
egregious case such as this the
legislature were to repudiate the court
because I think the court in the future
would then pick its fights more
carefully
what the court did in 93 I believe is
they just bit off a little more than
they could chew I think during the 80s
and early 90s there there was a series
of cases the court seemed to be poking a
stick at the legislature and I couldn't
figure out why this was and
uh you know I felt that it was like the
court was testing the legislature to see
how far it could go and when clarine
came along it was it was like an aha
moment to me they were they were setting
us up for something like this where they
made a major intrusion into a policy
area and figured that the legislature is
going to comply they didn't they didn't
realize how much resistance there would
be because they did not they did not
understand how much we would cling to
our desire to be an economical state
where local control of education is very
important that was what the Constitution
intended regardless of what you may have
heard from the previous witness that the
the evidence is overwhelming uh the
evidence cited by the court in in the
clar decision was dishonest because it
was because of what it didn't say it it
took a few excerpts and speeches and
letters which the the en thrust of them
was that yes education's important but
what really matters is what was actually
done in legislation before during the
Constitutional period and and afterwards
and uh it's quite plain there was no
State funding at all for Education until
the
1850s but the court found that to be not
convincing I don't know why that would
be the very best evidence of what was
the intention of the makers of the
Constitution what what the legislators
in the immediately preceding immediately
following years actually did and they
did not provide State funding for
Education what they
did article 83 working in conjunction
with article six of part one is they
directed the towns to provide education
at the town's
expense that was that was how article 83
and article 6 work
together other questions for this W
representative Oregon um thank you very
much I don't know whether you consider
it's an extending circumstance or not
but 1993 was uh 32 years ago so we're in
I guess our
16th uh B anual budget cycle since that
decision came down and hasn't the
legislator legislature
notwithstanding judge Rua's hearings and
various other ones um managed to get
away with passing budgets every two
years which provide a level of so-called
adequacy that's far below what it
actually cost to educate a student and
um and without really an Ade and without
an adequate Statewide funding so haven't
we actually like got away with not
funding education um according to the
standards of the laws it was back in
1993 so haven't we Haven we kind of like
triumphed over the courts in this
ongoing battle
so well to me it's been like a rope adob
strategy the the legislature has been
state of denial over what the
implications of Claremont one were and
uh so they so the legislators yeah I
don't know what was in the minds of my
fellow legislators when they passed
these bills whether they really honestly
believe these complied with Claremont or
they didn't but they to me they plainly
didn't they but they would pretend they
did and then that would just lead to
another school funding suit and a little
more cajoling from the court which as I
said before gets them more and more into
policymaking and then another bill comes
that and then we end up where we are now
where finally it's all come home to
roost we have the conval decision where
if it's if it's if it's upheld will
result in a massive tax increase in this
state to fund education according to the
figure for adequacy that uh that judge
ruoff
determined so we can't so the
legislature can't play around anymore
followup yes but wouldn't it wouldn't it
alternatively be within our powers I
mean this would be an unpopular decision
to be a lot of push back to just uh put
through it a Max of tax increase which
would hopefully would be offset at least
to some extent by lower local property
taxes and actually fund education
adequately so isn't that an option
that's uh before us this budget cycle I
mean not the option that's likely to be
taken but isn't that an option that
faces the people down the hall who are
writing the budget to actually go ahead
and fund education adequacy and put this
home and obviously increase taxes and
put the man to rest that way well I
I'm just getting a personal opinion here
I think the the appetite of the schools
for money is just Limitless so any tax
you you made would never be enough and I
and I'll tell you also I grew up in
Illinois and I remember very clearly
that in the late
60s the the voters were sold on a state
income tax on the promise that it would
reduce property taxes and and I'm sure
it did for a couple years but then
pretty soon they're both right back
where the the property tax are right
back where they were and and then you
have an income tax and I and I think
that's the way the income tax has been
sold in a lot of
states the promise that property taxes
would be lowered and it just doesn't
work out that way in the long
run other questions yes representative
Smith trying not to ask a question
um is your
concern that you believe that the
judicial branch has over stepped its
boundaries or is your
concern um that the
um the
monster that some people think it is of
an income tax would be the only way for
the state to in fact meet its
obligation to fund
education I I very much appreciate that
question because this something I would
have liked to have said and I should
have said at the outside as far as
education policy is concerned I'm just
agnostic my my I've seen my role in this
as being to reset who makes the policy I
don't want the judicial branch setting
education policy when the judicial
branch engages in judicial truly
judicial acts I'm a great admirer we are
very lucky to live in the state and and
we have a very good Judiciary but back
in 19993 they went off the rails in this
one case and I just wanted to restore
education funding policy and decision
making to where it belongs but as far as
what
policy the legisl in this wisdom decides
I'm I'm
neutral I'm a process guy in other words
not a policy
guy other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
I'd like submit Mr chairman I'd like to
submit oh of course yes absolutely
absolutely that's
fine um next I'm going to call Zak Shen
of uh conquered
please thank you very much nice see
thank you good to see
you good afternoon uh members of the
committee my name is Zach shien I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
school funding fairness project um I
have some testimony I can pass out offer
and will try not to repeat what's
already been said I know we've been
going for a bit here um but a little bit
more context around um we're in
opposition to both uh hcr1 and and HCR 7
which will be heard uh next um I think
it's important to provide a little more
context around kind of why the Claremont
lawsuits were initially filed and why
we've had ongoing lawsuits over the
years have been referenced throughout
the hearing uh today uh currently
there's a gap between what the state has
determined to be the cost of an adequate
education uh averages out about
$5,295 per student that's current
figures um when're actual expenditures
um average expenditures across the state
are closer to
$22,000 per student this average
expenditures there's no school district
in the state that spends less than three
times the amount of funding that they're
getting from the state in adequacy
funding um that is the same context
under which The Claremont lawsuits were
filed significant lack of funding from
the state to provide these services to
school districts in specific communities
with lower property tax um rates and and
higher property tax
burdens only 20% of all School District
Revenue actually comes from the state of
New Hampshire that's the smallest share
in the entire country uh whereas we rely
on 70% about comes from property
taxpayers which is the largest share of
school district Revenue that comes from
property taxes uh by a long shot uh in
the country uh these resolutions um
really are going to entrench more of the
disparities right these are statements
um that are looking to push back on the
rulings have been made we've heard a lot
about that and to the some of the
conversation earlier um the legislature
has to date not been um passing budgets
or policy that has moved towards um The
Claremont rulings which is why there are
continued lawsuits there are continued
lawsuits because there continues to be a
lack of funding from the state that
provides an adequate opportunity for an
adequate education to every school
district in the state
the court um to go back to the the kind
of conval rulings the court has been
very clear and when they were
deliberating you know when the court
case got remanded back down to the
Superior Court to judge ruof he was very
clear in thinking through what is my
role here in this debate if I say that
the $4,100 at the time in base adequacy
right that's the amount of money just
for the the bare minimum that providing
for base adequacy for Education if the
$4,100 of state's providing is not
enough but I've been told by the Supreme
Court to come back with a number and I
say it's 4101 right that wouldn't
material materially change anything the
lwuit would probably turn around and
come right back a dollar increase is not
going to change anything and so he was
very clear in his ruling and this is
about base adequacy only that the 7356
um figure that he came up with was a
minimum and that it was the legislator's
job to go and figure out what the actual
number is um actual cost of an adequate
education but that should be the floor
given that the floor of $4,100 was not
nearly enough um this would be a shift
of close to $500 million the order does
not say to increase funding by $500
million it could and should be a shift
of who is paying for that from local
property taxpayers to the state relative
to judicial overreach which I think is
what was testified as kind of the
impetus for for this um concurrent
resolution um there's been a lot of
suggesting um judicial overreach uh
judge ruof again um address those
potential concerns in his conval ruling
and I'll just read a quick quote from
him this a quote from the conval ruling
the court is likewise cognizant that
school funding is a complicated and
politically charged issue with a history
that suggests some level of judicial
intervention is now necessary among
other things though the legislature
hired Dr Baker to analyze school funding
issues and provide an informed
recommendation based adequacy Aid is
currently funded at less than half of
his recommended levels this is just one
example that calls into question whether
the politics of this issue are impeding
the state's constitutional obligation to
fully fund fully fund the opportunity
for children in the state to receive an
adequate education end quote so there's
a recognition there that and this was
brought up earlier we have Decades of
legislature making some changes to
school funding law and then court cases
coming back saying you're still not
providing enough in based adequacy
there's a heavy Reliance on local
property taxes the legisl making some
changes but not enough and more court
cases and he's addressing that there's
the political element of this issue
might
be and in our bin also is what is
holding this from moving forward um so
hgr you know 11 is we should be spending
time working on a solution to our school
funding problem relieving property tax
relieving the burden on property taxes
sending more funding to the districts
that need it most we know how to do that
there's many policy mechanisms not
having the legislature dig their heels
in more I'll end with one last point I'm
happy to answer any questions we've
heard a lot about kind of what
constituents and people want on this
issue um just to you know forther record
um the you know online signin for hcr1
there's 19 folks in support and as of a
few minuts ago 438 opposed and then
seven uh H 7 three in support and 400
against um just a measure of you know
kind of how other folks are weighing on
this issue and I'm happy to answer any
questions question representative
Oregon um actually I was doing some
quick calculations with the c oh I'm I'm
sorry I thought you had your hand up if
I oh oh I guess I will ask a question um
do you have a figure why not maybe you
don't have this off the top of your head
but do you have a figure on like how
much you spent in total on public
education in the
state total expenditures from everyone
are just the State um yeah both the
state and the school districts I think
the most recent figure is we spent about
$4 billion all in in our public
education system here in the state and
you're showing my top of the head math
20% of that is what's coming from the
state I'm don't have that top okay good
thanks yeah other questions for this W
yes representative Alexander and then
representative
petno thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question do you does your
organization have any evidence to show
that increased school funding will
increase student outcome comes
absolutely there is a huge body of
evidence what you're referring to is
this question of does money matter
that's kind of the lingo that's used
relative to researching what is the
impact on funding uh on outcomes and
there's a huge body of research that
shows that more funding not just you
know more funding everywhere for
everyone without um cause for
circumstances but we know that
increasing funding especially for
communities that have higher um
proportions of students coming from low
backgrounds um have higher proportion of
students um who have disabilities
there's plenty of evidence that shows
that that does have a positive impact on
student outcomes on Student Success
rates graduation rates kind of whatever
metric you'd like to use um there's
plenty of evidence that shows that both
New Hampshire uh and nationally and it's
the does money matter is kind of the
framing um that's used to answer that
question representative
pno thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so I've been
watching with interest as school
districts across the state have been
increasing their budgets in particular
um this year I know our own my own local
school district the budget is increasing
by
8.67% and my question to you is wouldn't
increasing adequacy just encourage the
school districts to spend even more
because they can just if we are getting
now they're now getting more money from
the state now they can offset and raise
the local property taxes they just keep
seem to keep raising their
budgets I think what's interesting about
budgets going up is it's a reflection of
true costs but right now I'm not sure
what community you live in off the top
of my head I apologize but um the
community you live in and and many
others around the state that are that
are proposing and passing increased
State budgets who's paying for that is
local property taxpayers so you're
having very local very specific debates
and conversations about if we increase
this now 8 you know something percent we
are going to pay for pretty much all of
that and that's passing from our
perspective that shows New Hampshire as
a whole we have a deep commitment to our
public education system even when we are
the ones footing the bill as property
taxpayers we are willing to invest and
continue to invest in our communities
the Nuance there is not every Community
can do that some communities are
proposing 8% increase and their property
tax payers are paying rates that are
three or four h times the rate of their
neighbors and that they don't have that
choice to say should we increase our our
budget to
you know increase the teacher pay or
whatever it is and so from our
perspective and I think there's evidence
to show this from when swept the
Statewide education property tax was
passed in 1999 it was an additive a new
additive tax at $6.60 right brand new
property tax around the
state paired with an education funding
formula to the previous question where
money was directed towards communities
with highest need you added a 660 tax
rate to everyone's Bill the average
average property tax rate dropped $4 per
thousand in the state and that's because
when you gave more funding to
communities that were really struggling
with their property taxes sure they
might have increased their spending
their budgets a little bit but they pass
a lot of that onto property tax savings
and with that comes back to the local
control issue of if districts have more
funding from the state they have the
ability to make those decisions locally
and we saw that in 1999 where a large
infusion of new cash with a new property
tax result in many communities the ones
that struggled the
passing those savings directly on their
property taxpayers I hope that was
helpful other question yes go ahead
representa yes thank you chair and thank
you for the question so I was just
looking at some facts here about the
Department of Education uh the US
Department not the local one here the
year 2000 it was $33 billion of outlays
4,900 employees last
year went from the 33 billion 25 years
ago to 251 billion only 4,200 employees
now um how how much of the funding comes
from federal
government so just to clarify your
question your question is how much of
the funding of the four billion I
mentioned to the total funding in New
Hampshire comes from the federal
government uh 9% this year um we expect
that to be it's normally around five or
6% the past four years it's been much
higher because of covid related funds
but we'll see that drop off um in in F
in the next the next year so we're we're
expect we're peeking out right about 9%
of of total education spending is coming
from the federal
government other questions for this
witness do you have a followup go ahead
yeah a follow-up question is if whereas
if you've seen the news lately the uh
doe at the federal level is on The
Chopping Block so to speak uh if that
funding is shifted to Local Schools or
local you know state level how would
that affect this
so just so I understand your question if
the amount of federal funding that we're
currently getting stops or is
reduced if the federal funding
increases so I guess I'm not following
so my understanding of the conversation
of the federal level is not that they
are considering increasing funding to
the states is that they are considering
decreasing funding if anything so I I
guess to answer the question if we got
more money from the Feds that would be
great um it would I think reduce a lot
of these tensions that we're talking
about I don't think that's the direction
that the conversations are going at
least my understanding of the federal
conversations thank you other questions
for this witness seeing none thank you
very much sir thank you next I'm going
to call on Sandra Canon please from
Atkinson
um thank you for letting me speak um I
just wanted to say that can you hear it
you know can I get you a little get just
get a little closer to the microphone
thank you okay um thank you for letting
me speak um I just really want to point
out that what the woman from miramac
said about how local communities are
doing it she made some good points there
um I also feel that the judicial even
though the education committee hasn't
been listening to them as a constituent
I feel like they have to stay somewhat
involved to try to keep pushing that and
if all of a sudden they're cut out then
there's no reason for the education
committee to do anything um I'm also
really concerned about um the education
Freedom accounts which there's
absolutely no accountability for our tax
dollars going to that I do see a court
case coming probably concerning that
since there's no way for us to have any
um information um so if if we're to stop
all this then that means that the courts
can't get involved in another issue
related to
education um I also want to go that the
perception is with all these court cases
the perception is that the education
committee is doing nothing we are
getting no more funding at all um there
was even a bill that came up um House
Bill 550 to increase the amount of money
to that
$7,000 that um Zach talked about um and
that was shot down in committee um and I
just feel like they're not listening um
in that all this burden is being put on
taxpayers okay to fund education we're
not ask I mean Zach isn't asking for a
lot more from the state but enough to
make it a little bit better I don't know
how many of you have heard about the tax
the timberlan tax revolt that happened
this year taxes are a huge issue for
homeowners and to put it in perspective
the dividends and interest tax was
phased out that affected the rich the
business taxes um were decreased okay um
nothing has been done for the homeowners
and I feel if the judicial is no longer
involved in any of these education
issues that still nothing will happen
Okay but the timberlan tax revolt at our
deliberative session this year our
budget that was proposed by the school
district and the um um budget committee
was a decrease okay by about I'm not
sure the numbers but it was a decrease
we were going to bit less on our
taxes um and then a group came
in and if you want to read the article
it's out there online a group came in
and slashed our budget by $6.7 million
down to 81 million where the school
district says 83 million is what we have
committed and our budget was 88 million
so there was some wiggle room in there
maybe it could have come down a little
bit but it went all the way to 81
million now if that passes um because
people are fed up with the taxes that's
going to hugely affect our school
district and I just really feel that I
want the judicial to stay involved to
keep putting pressure on the education
committee to do what is
representative
P thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question are you aware by
any chance that in the last bium the
legislature increased um funding for
public schools by $69. one
million um I don't know the numbers on
that I know they have increased it for
Education Freedom accounts and that they
want to open that up to a lot more
people they seem to have money for that
but not money to increase for the public
schools you follow
up thank you thank you and thank you
again for taking my question are you
aware that the funding for Education
Freedom accounts accounts for only for
accounts for less than 1% of the overall
spend education spending in the state of
New Hampshire it is right now but if it
gets opened up it's going to be a lot
more and I feel like public education is
is um is is important
uh country's built on public
education any other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
next I'm going to call on Ann Marie
Banfield
please good
afternoon some of you may know me
because you've seen me in the education
um policy group my name is Amry Banfield
I'm education researcher I'm a parental
rights advocate in New Hampshire and I
focus on academic excellence in the
classro and I've been doing this for 20
years and I haven't collected a
dime um so what we are seeing right now
and I think we can even see it in this
room is there seems to be let's blame
the state for sometimes irresponsible
School budgets and I say irresponsible
School budgets because I look at them I
serve on the Bedford taxpayers
Association for 10 years I'm now running
for um budget Committee in h in
Northampton because I dig I dig
deeper and what I find sometimes going
on in schools is quite frankly wasteful
spending now I'm not I'm I'm making that
statement not for every single school
but I'm saying that I see it I see it in
my district I see it in other
districts uh you mentioned something
about um increased spending in gets you
better results when I lived in Bedford
we had great results but what it doesn't
account for is all the kids that go to
private tutoring in
Bedford so there's a lot of information
in some of these scores that are not
always app parent so you could increase
spending all you want in your schools
but if you're not still providing a good
education the parents in the in the rich
districts are going to make sure their
kids don't fall through the
cracks um
um so yes I do look at what's going on
in the schools I thank the attorneys who
came up here I'm certainly not going to
speak on that because I'm not an
attorney and I'm not going to speak on
that but I am going to tell you that for
instance in miramac you know they spend
$90,000 on a math program that includes
social emotional learning and it
includes Fine Arts and I have to ask
where's the math so when I look at
scores when I look at where the spending
is going and they have multiple programs
in their
schools my question to you is do you
just want to give that over more money
or would it be you know I'm a lobbyist I
come to the education committee and I
tell them about these issues I would
like to go to them and say you know what
there are probably some schools in the
state that need funding and we need to
focus on them teachers are having to
purchase their own materials in their
classroom while we're spending $90,000
on a math program that many teachers
don't even like so those are the kinds
of things that I get to do as a lobbyist
but guess what I can't go before the
judicial branch and say any of this
because that's not my role and that's
not the role of the judicial branch so
now we've got them making these
decisions that I can't weigh in on and
explain some of this to you or explain
some of it to the education funding
group um committee I'm sorry so that's
why I think it's important to take back
this role of
legislators and stop letting the
Judiciary
Branch basically do your function and it
it now it allows me and allows other
people with differing views maybe there
is a school district that needs money
let them come up and tell you let them
come up and tell you look this is what
we've got going on
but I'm telling you in Northampton we're
spending
$39,000 per student in our district if
our budget passes and our budget is
pretty much close to the default so it's
going to pass so we're spending
$39,000 per student in my district and
it's up to me when I run as a budget
Committee
Member to now decide on what and and I
and I engage my budget committee to the
point where I'm probably in a since but
seriously I do engage in this process
and that's what we all can do in our own
local towns but I don't get to do this
with the Judiciary Branch who gets to
now interpret law and yes I do see see
it as an
overreach did you know that most
administrators um at the SAU level are
making more than the governor the
commissioner and the Attorney General in
almost probably every school district in
the state so there's ways that that we
can bring down property taxes if we
really wanted to the the problem is is
that most local communities don't want
to do that hard work they don't want to
make those decisions and so that's why a
lot of times the state give us more
money you're not you're not giving us
enough well maybe it's because like I
think the governor pointed out and I
think Sharon Carson Senator Carson
pointed out that
we're you know we're not going to fund
your bad decisions or we're not going to
fund you're overspending and I would
agree with that but at the same time I
do understand that there is a need for
schools to get the
funding
um I just want to make sure I've hit
everything up I think I have um yeah
that's all I wanted to say thank you
thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very
much is there anyone else here who
wishes to be heard on uh house
concurrent resolution
11 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on house concurrent resolution
11 and I'm going to uh open the hearing
on uh house resolution
7 hang
on and I will uh recognize the prime
sponsor representative beler
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee very much my pleasure to
be here this afternoon to introduce
this for the record representative Mike
beler Carroll County District
4 first let me say that despite this
body recently demonstrating that it does
have an appetite to exercise its
impeachment Powers when warranted as a
point of clarity this resolution is not
articles of impeachment and should it
pass the house it does not affect
impeachment rather it authorizes a house
investigation most probably taking the
form of a brief special
committee to look at the issue
investigate the issue and render a
recommendation on whether to proceed
with articles of impeachment
there is substantial cause at present to
believe that impeachment may be
inappropriate remedy in this
case it appears that the judge in this
particular decision is guilty of the
following usurpation of the exclusive
powers of this legislature to both
allocate funds and Levy
taxes extr ex to extreme judicial
activism on behalf of a partisan
political cause thereby seeking to
bypass us as the political body and
perhaps more
importantly bypassing the people of this
state who elected us to represent
them three
imprudence and usurpation of the greater
powers of the New Hampshire Supreme
Court by refusing using to stay the
order pending a review by the only
constitutionally established Court in
this state the Supreme Court allow me to
provide some brief preemptive answers to
some of the arguments that you might see
against
this first it might be argued that the
financial calculations utilized in this
opinion were good and
correct however it can also be aru
argued reasonably that they were not
good and correct and that a variety of
other paradigms exist for funding of
public
education that were not considered here
the existence of these alternate
paradigms fundamentally makes this a
policy issue and a policy issue is
fundamentally a political issue and this
is the political branch of
government the the Judiciary is supposed
to be
apolitical making findings of fact and
Faithfully applying the law that is the
extent of the judiciary's delegated
authority second it might be argued that
the Judiciary is a co-equal branch of
government and therefore should be able
to render this sort of
opinion setting aside the previous
argument that proves the General
falsehood of that it's also specifically
false the only portion of the Judiciary
that enjoys a co-equal status with this
legislature and the executive is the
branch is the part of the Judiciary
established by the Constitution which is
the Supreme Court of New
Hampshire the lower courts by contrast
are not co-equal they exist under this
branch of government and regulated by
this branch of government therefore Not
only was this decision extreme overreach
usurping legislative Authority it was
also usurping the co-ee equality of the
Supreme
Court third it might be argued that this
opinion is a logical extension of
previous Supreme Court
president however the reality is that
this decision so far exceeded any prior
New Hampshire judicial decision that
even assuming a full a full agreement
with all previous
precedents this cannot be reasonably
extended as a as a logical extension of
them no prior judicial opinion has made
has made specific and radical funding
demands of this body that also implicate
the taxation authority of this body
we're talking about amount of money here
that is somewhere between 5 and 6% I
think of the biannual budget represented
just in this judicial
decision fourth it has been suggested
that such impeachment proceedings might
threaten the independence of the
Judiciary that argument lies entirely in
a faulty premise the Judiciary is no
more independent than the executive or
than the legislature
we exist as co-equal
branches that doesn't mean the same it
means we have different delegated powers
with which to hold each other
accountable and responsible to the
constitution in this light these
Arguments for judicial Independence to
prevent us from weighing in on our own
territory of policy is little more than
an argument for judicial Supremacy and a
form of oligarchy
that is not what we
are in summary it appears to me that
this judge in this case thought himself
King of New
Hampshire that duty to correct this
error is ours alone nobody else has the
authority to fix this problem if we fail
now we can and should expect that the
next decisions rendered will be even
more radical and we might just find that
our Republic form of government is
irrecoverable if we do not act now thank
you and I will take questions I'm sorry
questions for the representative
organ yes uh which uh I guess there was
a Kuku versus New Hampshire in 2019 in
2024 I haven't looked at the court
docket for I guess there's two court
cases rather than one so that uh I mean
I guess we can get this we can we can
get this through our own channels but
that's something you can provide provide
the committee so you can see like
exactly what it is you're talking about
what exactly what it is you're
complaining about um
so I'm not entirely sure I understand
the question um I guess the other
question is uh what's the status of this
case in the courts so like the uh I I
know he made an order which then was up
I think it was upheld by the Supreme
Court I was just sort of looking I just
thank you that that but then there's a
second lawsuit I guess too this filed
last year I guess or is that correct
uh let me take the first question first
then you can repeat the second one
because I didn't quite catch it so the
first answer would be um it is my
understanding that the Supreme Court did
step in to stay this decision thankfully
where the judge himself had refused to
stay it and it's now being seen before
The Supreme Court and pending a decision
which is why I think it's even more
important right now to take some action
and again passing this resolution does
not mean impeachment it means
investigation that might lead to
impeachment and I think it's extremely
important that we signal to the entire
Judiciary that this branch of government
takes our powers very seriously and
we're prepared to take action on it
because the last bill you heard was
talking about effectively what could be
called the Constitutional crisis and if
you don't want a constitutional crisis
you need to prevent it before the
decision happens other questions for
this witness representative tur yeah
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
the question um I think I heard in your
introduction of the bill you claimed one
of the the issues leading to this was
judicial activism on a partisan
political cause and I was hoping you
could clarify that are you are you
saying that the funding of public
education and how it's paid for is in
fact a partisan political
cause yes absolutely there's multiple
different um paradigms by which a public
education can be offered presently in
this state we have not just a
traditional government run schools we
also have efas and other uh available
options for people to provide a publicly
funded education to their children and
we fight all the time you can look at
the partisan breakdown of the votes of
course these are partisan issues and of
course that's what the the judge was
weighing in
on are questions for this
witness thank you very much
sir uh next I'm going to call on Caitlyn
Bernier please
yep there you go um I've done this
already uh good afternoon honorable
chairperson and members of the J
Judiciary Committee thank you for taking
the time to listen to My Testimony my
name is Caitlyn Bernie here and I live
in marac and I'm here in opposition of
hr7 um
I understand that there is the
separation of powers and that um the
gentleman before was just speaking about
how um they how you're they're ready to
be acted upon here and that action is
going to be done but this was at least
five years ago that this first one came
out um and we've had uh
continued um lawsuit or uh cases that
you guys have spoken about um where
you're uh saying that the um committee
is um going to make a decision and move
on uh increasing the cost um or or of
adequate education or a um and none of
that has happened yet um so I I can
understand um that everybody has like
you know your own place and role um but
if things aren't being done and the
increase isn't there um how else are we
supposed to get
anything uh improved um who is going to
take action who is going to uh make sure
that we increase and take care of our
students and our um Community I the
comment before about um property taxes
um we in my town in marac which was
already spoken about um we did approve
the budget because we do value our
education and we have seen our uh
reading scores are above the state
average um across the board for all
grades because we have invested extra
money and gone above and uh had hearings
to approve things you I don't mean to
interrupt me but we seem to be getting a
little this is the bill here is dealing
with the correct I did get off topic
sorry I was just thinking back to that
um you're right I apologize um this um I
I think that the main question shouldn't
be um should we be trying to investigate
this uh judge but
rather what are we doing about the
inadequate Aid that we are currently
providing to our towns and districts to
educate their students all right thank
you very thank you thank you questions
for this witness seeing none thank you
uh Sandra Canon
please miss
Canon um okay I don't I guess Miss Canon
is not here I think she may have been I
thought she might have been here earlier
but anyway all right um is there anyone
else here who wishes to be heard on uh
house resolution
7 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on house resolution
pardon right right and I'm going to take
I'm actually going to take a minute
because for some reason I don't have the
next bill in my notebook and I'm going
to get a copy
of was this vacated
says
oh I know
I
think all right
uh okay um you know I you know what this
how you do how's it down where this bill
originally went to County and Municipal
and we got it late and I mean it's it's
in it's before Judiciary but but it was
referred to us late I think or
transferred and that's why we don't have
it are there more copies back there uh
there's more copies over there but you
can take you have this you this no no no
that's all right sure
okay
okay all
right all
right all right you are you all okay all
right great all right so uh I'm going to
open the hearing um on on House Bill 132
FN and Rec recognize the prime sponsor
representative lad thank you
representative thank you very much Mr
chairman and members of the Judiciary
Committee uh for the record my name is
Rick lad I come from havil havil New
Hampshire and I uh represented Grafton
five that's a number of smaller towns up
around Benton landf Warren pymont and
the center being being haval um this
bill which I'm presenting today is HB
and just a little background why I'm
sort of out of my wheelhouse by being
over here in judiciary instead of on the
other side of the street here in
education um I was approached by a
citizen in
Pont roughly last
March and asked what do I do when we
have a
relative that we have not dealt with in
this town for years and years and years
and hasn't taken anybody's
advice and is Rock Bottom poor right now
and they're coming after us to support
this
individual and they say there's this
statute and the statute which you have
before you that I gave you is 165
covid-19 liability for
support on the back side it just takes
you roughly quickly through that process
which this person was starting to go
through with their select board and this
is in the small town of Pont roughly 600
plus uh people living in the town
what it does is that it require and and
this bill was developed when I looked at
the last time it was last change in
1986 85 prior to that where they kind of
shrunk it down quite a bit and it was
initially back in 1925 1933 so we're
talking about the Dust bow days and the
roaring roaring 20s and and what
resulted back in the 30s um this person
was a had a relative right there in the
same town of pmod
and the law re basically says right now
if there's a relationship and they talk
about the relationship being a father a
mother a stepfather step mother son
daughter husband or
wife and it deals about the poor person
that needs that support within that
community and what the select board was
tasked to do in accordance with this law
right here it could also be a county
commissioner or an overseer of the
public welfare or your welfare officer
for your town now
would look at you and say okay you may
have to help pay for the costs of this
person even though the person's been
doing everything contrary to what you
believe in even though you haven't met
this person in your community for months
and years uh you are Bloodline with this
particular
individual and so the board then decides
whether you have the means the wherewith
all to help and it says right within it
the weekly income more than sufficient
for
yourself and this individual did have
income above and
beyond and others in the town did as
well and had been helping and it had
just not done a darn
thing and so when we went when you go
further with it then the people that are
conducting that meeting the county
commissioner or the selectman or the
overseer Seer if such person refuses to
comply why would they above order to
help then the person shall be summoned
to appear in court pursuant to RSA 165
covid-19 a hearing is conducted if the
poor person is found to be in need of
assistance and if the relationship is
able to render assistance the court May
decree relation shall furnace this
assistance but what happens if that
individual
refuses according to the law which you
have in front of you right now they can
be deemed in contempt of court and they
can be
imprisoned for no more than 90 days no
fewer than 60 days um and if there is no
relationship in town to take care of
this it falls upon the city or the town
take care of the
individual so right now the the request
you have through this is to delete the
whole chapter there kind of outdated law
uh we have a lot of issues going on in
communities where people are related and
even those families within are not
talking with each other due to somebody
maybe um doing some awful things and uh
so that's the gist of what's coming
forward to you this was an actual
experience which occurred up there I do
not know what the outcome was the person
still walking around obviously wasn't
put in jail but it's uh seems to be a
pretty harsh you know you
know impact on a family that just just
you know we had these obligations to
send our kids to college that we were
doing this and this and this and this we
don't have any more money to put on this
person over here which in fact we don't
want anything to do it but we're aligned
by Blood thank you very much Mr chair
and that's the gist of this conversation
right thank you representative uh
representative Mo please yes thank you
chair and thank you for the question uh
it says um rarely used can you quantify
rarely I I have not when I presented
this to the people over across the
street at o and the researchers they
went through and said wow we really
don't know much about this in fact it
really belongs you know out of the
statute because it's it's kind of
outdated the way this is done there's so
much transy now in our in our society
and um I'm not I'm not saying that we
shouldn't be helping people but I don't
think it should be necessarily placed on
that family uh but I can't tell you
specifically when it was last used if in
fact it was even used other than what I
see in what happened at one time in
permont followup quick followup so this
is kind of like one of those antiqua
rules you can't have more than 20
chickens living in your house or some
you know something ridiculous that
nobody ever enforces because doesn't
happen we have a lot of this actually if
you look hard at our statutes you're
going to come across these things which
occur and somebody digs it out and uses
it applies it once or twice and here we
are all right representative orgon you
had a question um yes would you believe
that is law is probably even older than
1925 I think the thing they found 1925
is like something they passed as a
chapter law rather than as that's
exactly what it says so RS 668 is
probably much older even than 19 you're
probably correct yeah all right other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you much thank you very much
representative lad next I'm gonna call
on uh Stephen Tower
please good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee I'm Steve Tower
with New Hampshire Legal Assistant um I
sort of head all of our involvement in
the local Welfare Law at nhla so I'm
sort of our local expert on it uh we are
not taking a position in favor or in
opposition of this bill um but I did
want to testify to provide some
additional information having spoken to
Mr Marsh behind me who will be
testifying later on I think a lot of
what my plan testimony would be
duplicative so I'll just keep it short
um in addition to uh RSA 165 colon 19
which identifies the legally liable
relatives and includes this language
about being able to enforce the
liability RSA 165 colon 20 also allows
towns to be reimbursed for expenses that
were incurred from Legally liable
relatives so were this section of the
statute to be repealed um I think RSA
165 colon 20 would also need to be
amended
um uh beyond that I'll just state that
back in
2021 um I sent out a number of 91a
information requests to towns to ask an
just kind of get a feel for how the
local Welfare Law is working in
different parts of the state I sent them
out to Major municipalities and then a
handful of the smaller municipalities I
sent out about 50 and all and one of the
questions I asked was had any Town ever
recovered expenses from a legally liable
relative in the last 10 years under RSA
col 20 um and uh all of the towns that
responded stated that they had not so I
think at a minimum there's not a lot of
going to the courts to enforce the
legally liable relative um but as uh Mr
Marsh will probably testify towns do
sometimes use the existence of the
statute to call up legally liable
relatives and say hey can you take this
person in give them shelter so that
we're not paying for it um if you don't
we technically could go after you even
if a town generally won't um so I think
that's the extent of my testimony if
anyone had any questions I'm happy to
answer them um but you know I'm sorry
could could you just uh I think
representative lad referenced it but I
to be honest I've forgotten exactly the
Lang the language you use who are the
people that are what is the scope of the
relative relationship that uh makes you
subject to the statute um it is it's um
oh thank you mother father son daughter
brother sister I believe okay
um that okay
okay right right right right right right
right and and there are certain
situations where a person who uh may
have that relationship connection but
say you know they grew up in abusive
household and they they haven't spoken
to their family in 30 years or perhaps
the legally liable mother of somebody
um their child is battling in an
addiction and has previously taken all
of their jewelry and pwned it and so
there's you know a breakdown in the
relationship in that way so
um sometimes there isn't that tight
family connection that uh I
think it may be imagined when this bill
was passed um but um I'm sure everyone
could imagine the situations where maybe
not everyone in a family gets along
super well all right questions questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir next I'm going to call on Todd Marsh
please yes good idea good afternoon uh
honorable chairperson members of the
committee uh yes my name is Todd Marsh I
am the President of the New Hampshire
local welfare administrators Association
um the methology section um methodology
uh section of the HB 132 States the
following however according to the local
welfare administrators Association the
provision is sometimes used but
infrequently I am the President of the
New Hampshire local Welfare Association
as I stated and I will plainly State I
am not aware nor is our board of
directors aware of being formally
consulted regarding the bill um so I
appreciate being here today
um at a time of increasing assistance
expenditures for
municipalities uh we should not
eliminate a reimbursement option to
municipalities that has existed for many
decades um although it may be used
infrequently um it is used
frequently enough to maintain an
important reimbursement option for
municipalities um for local taxpayers
it is vital to allow municipalities to
seek reimbursement from legal legally
liable legally liable relatives in the
line of as it was indicated father
mother stepfather stepfather um
stepfather stepmother adult son adult
daughter husband or wife as long as
reimbursement does not cause financial
hardship
um on that legally liable relative
meaning the reimbursement does not cause
an inability for that relative to pay
the basic Livy
expenses in that situation reimbursement
is not
sought um the current
law um the value of the current law
Beyond simply the actual
reimbursement
um but the potential the value of it is
the potential a municipality could seek
reimbursement from Legally liable
relatives why because the close family
members mentioned are often likely to
assist their family member in need with
just the prospect of the municipality uh
could seek
reimbursement uh types of assistance
when reimbursement is either discussed
or actively sought the most are unhal
situations um as indicated we we are we
try to be very sensitive about that is
is domestic violence involved sexual uh
harassment violence um so we practice
situational
flexibility um Municipal welfare
practices flexible decision- making as I
indicated when deciding to use legal
legally liable relative the the legally
liable relative law which is often based
on family Dynamics including known or
unknown where it's a family we're not
going to spend two months trying to
locate um an adult son that lives in
Arizona somewhere
um for reimbursements meaning we we may
not contact and we likely will not
contact a family member if a resident is
seeking assistance with $125 for an
electric bill because of a disconnect
status uh but we may for emergency
housing extended rental payments burial
cremation assistance due to the
cost maintaining the option for
municipalities including the taxpayers
that pay for
assistance uh to seek reimbursement is
important to minimize cost to
taxpayers with minimal effect on the
applicant because it has no effect on
the bearing of the decision that we make
on the applicant
um the association representing the
municipal Welfare Offices throughout the
state ask you to oppose this
well-intended and I and I believe it is
but I think too many con but full of
consequences bill in front of you right
representative
Smith thank you so much for for being
here um I'm a little confused and and
maybe well maybe I'm tired um no
actually I am tired so that I'm not
confused about um can you tell me um go
back two years 5 years 10 years 20 years
exactly how many
times uh welfare
administrators have in fact used this to
collect
money I cannot give you numbers because
it's not collected what I can state
um is that having consulted our board of
directors which is made up of both large
and small
municipalities um that they were very
clear that we should be opposing this
bill um that it may not be used on a
daily basis but it is
used um and often times it's the mention
of as it was indicated earlier that this
law exists that may result in a family
member a close family member
um rethinking and and um deciding to
potentially assist their family member
um who was in need and if they cannot
then the person will come into our
office if I could just follow up um I
read the fiscal note I read it twice I
then actually gave my copy to someone
else so I don't I maybe because I'm
tired I don't remember but it seemed to
indicate that there was basically what
is known in the vernacular as di
Minimus um
Financial uh return in this is that
incorrect are you saying that the only
are you the only thing that this is good
for is to remind
people if reminding people that they
have an obligation to their family if
that's not quite enough but to say to
them they might
be I guess the language from the period
is they might be putting the
hcal um that that causes them to do
something that they wouldn't otherwise
do I would state that
um if this bill was to pass yes um there
would be a cost to to the municipalities
due due to the reasons that you
indicated there are family members it it
is there are family members that do
assist because of the law because of a
letter that may be sent out they
absolutely do um but then why can't you
give me any numbers to tell me how much
money has come in because of this it's
challenging to do because I'm sorry I
apologize that's okay I I appreciate the
I I appreciate the question
um because of the nature of local
welfare throughout the state it would be
very challenging to get those numbers
especially in the time that really that
I had but um but we do represent local
welfare departments throughout the state
large cities small towns some towns use
it more than others um but it would be
at a cost to can I give you a quick
example of a situation if you don't mind
okay thank you um for um I'll use the
city of
Rochester uh if a if an if an adult son
comes into our
office um unfortunately seeking burial
Assistance or cremation assistance
um for his
mom um we will um after you have a good
conversation we will thoughtfully remind
of the it is in our application of the
law um and that they do have a right to
come in if they cannot afford to pay
themselves um and however I would say
about half the time they come into our
office because I think they they have a
chance to think and
pause and uh they can self-pay
themselves they will um whereas if the
law did not exist it could change that
Dynamic right and if they can't pay it
they can come into our office absolutely
all right representative Morton and then
representative tur so um so you say that
it's not collected as far as the numbers
um and this applies to people of every
age that being said I'll I'll give some
statistics we know that 10,000 Americans
every day turn 65 and and we know that
there's a a growing number of elderly
people and 70% of people over the age of
65 will need long-term care that would
be something that would fall into this
only 16% of people above the age of 65
have insurance to pay for that um a very
small percentage probably less than 10%
can financially afford it themselves so
that's where Medicaid would kick in
question here yeah absolutely because
the vast majority I I do long-term care
insurance for living so
the vast majority of people who receive
care and some younger people as well get
that care from family members so is is
your point being that the people find
out that the family member needs care
because they've been you know um they
haven't been in contact with each other
for a while or whatever and that's
helped put people back together and help
them get that care because the vast
majority do get care from family members
statistically I will say well in a in a
past career life I also sold long-ter
care insurance 20 plus years ago that
was very difficult to sell by the way
because nobody believes they're going to
a nursing home and anyway um I I should
state that New Hampshire local welfare
does not pay for long-term care um for
for that kind of service um so I think
that would that would not be an issue
all right representative
tur yeah thanks um thanks for taking the
question I'm just curious just given the
age I guess that we've heard of this uh
law um how does it interact with sort of
the programs that have been put in place
particularly at the federal level since
then like TANF and and um the other the
other supports that are meant to sort of
supplement people's needs oh thank you
for the question it does not directly
interact with tanif and and state
Services it is more targeted towards
local welfare
representative
bur thank you Mr
chair um I want to follow up first with
representative Smith's question uh
because the way this seems to work is if
somebody's asked to pay and doesn't wish
to they uh shall be uh summoned into
court uh if you folks or Commissioners
whoever request it right so do we have a
number of how many people have gone
through the court
process that should be easily determined
right I do not I I do not um the the
it's I don't have I do not have access
to the individual municipalities if I
had more time perhaps we could come up
with that um I just we just don't have
those do you have a sense whether it's
in one digigit tw digigit three-digit
number as far as municipalities as far
as people that actually go take people
to court summon to court under this
section yeah I would say municipalities
that um follow
through uh not
many so would it be a so would is is a
would it be a fair characterization of
your testimony that municipalities kind
of like this
law
because even though it's very unlikely
that they're ever going to try to carry
through on it it gives them a little bit
of a hammer to for lack of this is my
term not yours but for lack of a for
lack of a better term to some extent at
least coer or persuade people that you
know um you better you ought to pay up
because if not we could take it to court
right
um so
it's
situational right and uh the reminder
that the that the law exists does help
our offices when I say help our offices
I also mean local taxpayers okay right
representative bir goad without a hammer
to to follow up this this gentle letter
I assume it says to let's say a
90-year-old person that if you don't
help out including if you refuse to go
back to
work um you will be subject potentially
to a mandatory jail term is that the
kind and gentle letter you're referring
to based on the statute it could be done
based on reality and I've been doing
local welfare for 21 years it doesn't
that does not
happen all right other qu yes
representative trip
when you first started you uh uh said
which RSA you uh operate under could you
uh tell us that one again yeah RSA
165 and the uh relative liability is RSA
165 colon 19 say again RSA 165 colon 19
is the legally liable relative I thought
that was a different one sorry all right
any other questions for this witness
well representative Manos thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question it sounds to me from your
testimony that there's sort of an
informal process that goes on here and
I'm curious about that so in this
informal process let's say you have
somebody who's homeless maybe with some
mental illness problems or addiction
problems and there's a question of
domestic violence or not it sounds like
it can be cyclical that the person can
maybe stay put with the sister for for a
while and then they leave again
and it's who who makes that judge who's
making those judgments it sounds like
it's almost for lack of a better word
handholding um and and I'm just curious
about that so I just for some
clarification if a so if a person who
was unhoused or in in a challenging
situation is bouncing or including
staying with a
sister
um how would we manage that I just want
to make sure that's my question it seems
like there's an ongoing informal process
over time and people are exercising
judgment and making judgments and
Arrangement works for a while and then
stops working and right yes that
absolutely does happen where you know in
our in our field we often call it cou
Sur
um um and that's what people call it who
are who are who are unfortunately going
through those
situations um and you know if someone's
staying with a sister in that situation
where local welfare is not paying
anything um and I will state to to
further clarify I think it's if someone
approaches our office and they're 18
years old 19 years old stating oh my my
mother just kicked me out right and and
maybe that adult has a
child um we will listen to the situation
because we do certainly do not want to
refer them back into a harmful situation
even if it saves money right it's not
okay um but if their story sounds like
you know maybe we should make a phone
call to that to that parent we may very
well do that and we could cite the law
normally we don't need to normally I can
say Hey you know your daughter's here
with your grand child um yeah is it okay
if they come back oh
absolutely right but we have that law in
order to point to if we need to and what
we do um yes judgments are made because
we're constantly solution finding it
it's what local welfare does is not
categorical
assistance um whereas in tanif uh
Medicaid it's more these are the numbers
in the in the in the the decisions are
primarily noted by by the numbers in
local welfare which is what I enjoy
about it actually the numbers matter the
numbers matter the budgets matter but
we're going to ask the question what's
going on what's your situation because
that matters too it helps us to problem
solve right so it it that's how our
system local welfare Works
representative Mort yes thank you um and
thank you for the question you're
welcome so Harbor care is is that
another resource rather than put aing it
back on the towns or or United Way or I
mean are there other resources or is
this either you know your your brother
helps you or you know the town's going
to have to pay for it and we're going to
go after you um so if we can reasonably
refer elsewhere we will if timing and
and the nature of the
emergency um
uh makes it okay to do so
we we will but we we need to determine
You Know What's the timing is there
truly a resource that's available at
4:00 on a
Friday um and and we are the ones with a
legal obligation you know United Way and
some others not necessar they're not um
but we will we will uh refer when it's
reasonably possible to do so we
collaborate with many helping providers
and sometimes it's a puzzle of
assistance when we can do that sometimes
it takes time to do um but if we can
refer we will um but when it comes down
to it literally I try not to use that
word too often but the buik
stops all right all right thank you any
any other question representative
kop thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question um I just have a
question so I'm not sure if you're
familiar with the JIS V Emerson case
from 1844 which is I think we're
absolutely not
okay so I think that that was it's a New
Hampshire Supreme Court case which
basically said that the that the
families would you believe that it's a
New Hampshire Supreme Court case that
basically said that a family member is
responsible and including a CH uh a
child of a parent is responsible to take
care of their their parent it was a it
was a case that the child didn't want to
pay for the the parents welfare um and I
was told back in
2023 that that's where this law came
from and that even if we repealed it
that common law basically said we had to
do it anyway so do you still believe
that that would be the case that common
law would kind of make us do this anyway
even if we repealed this well not being
an attorney I need to I need to be
careful with it with the answer to that
um I will say this um in a situation
that I mentioned earlier adult son comes
in could be a daughter regarding the
passing of his mother right um and the
question is on our application regarding
legally liable relatives it's on every
application throughout State okay um one
way I may phrase it I may say something
like you know the way new the state of
New Hampshire looks at this is family
first if
possible if possible and if they can't
that's why we exist and so we we put it
out there um and the person decides all
right can I reasonably do this myself
there are family members that simply who
could assist who just but for whatever
reason you know you decide not to um all
right so I think I overly answered your
question right any other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much I appreciate it thank you all right
is there anyone else who wishes to be
heard on uh House Bill 132 Mr chair um I
my friends in the municipal Association
are out back and I'm just wondering if
they have an opinion on this bill and if
they'd like to weigh in on it um I would
certainly like to hear their opinion
anybody else uh anybody here at the back
of the room that wants to weigh in on
hb32 they they seem to be indicating no
wh I'm sorry do you are you coming
up yeah fill it out while you're G
that's fine I for one care a lot about
what the municipal Association has to
say so I'm glad they're here thank
you good afternoon uh my name is Sarah
Burke Cohen I am from the new Municipal
Association and um thank you for that
representative Alexander I appreciate it
we do oppose this bill um in the fiscal
note New Hampshire Municipal Association
I think um representative Smith
mentioned um
we we don't see that there's a huge cost
shift um if this if this bill passed
however we do agree with the local
Welfare Association that allowing it to
still be in place does assist um with
some uh welfare officers in um ensuring
that some of the applicants are able
some of the applicants get assistance
from their family members at the the
first step and not the town at the first
step all right any other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much anyone else that wishes to be heard
on
hb32 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that and I think we are done
which is good because I need to get to
finance uh to uh
t uh just just for the members of the
committee um it will be in the notice
for this week but don't don't forget I
mean obviously we have session tomorrow
but we're going to have an executive
session next Monday at starting at 100
p.m um have to exec a bunch of bills and
the other thing I want to say just for
the I'm sure representative Smith has
arrangements for her caucus but for my
caucus we're probably gonna have another
uh Zoom meeting this Sunday night and
I'll send out a notice uh on that of for
the the bills we're going to exec on
Monday all right with that thanks very
much everybody for hanging
in for